I'm on this antidepressant I don't feel
great by the way like I still feel
depressed because I was absolutely
wanting to like end my life I probably
should be on a higher dosage if if
you're going by what the doctor says but
I can't because when I go on a higher
dosage I end up wanting to piss all
through the night and I can't even
[__] live like you know what I mean
like I can't even wake up in the morning
I literally want to have an orgasm and
be able to and sleep so I need a certain
amount just to stop myself from killing
everybody
how many of the people out there are
feeling like me probably a lot
[Music]
do that
what are you [__] is wrong with it you
know how they play
[Applause]
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
today I am joined by one of my favorite
online creators Elise Michael's expert
in men's mental health thanks for coming
thank you so much for having me I'm
super excited to be here yeah we've been
planning this for a while and uh the
reason your content hit me is a you
really understand men's mental health
you are truly an expert I've never heard
anyone communicate our feelings the way
you do in like you put it so simply and
you you men listen to your stuff and it
goes viral all the time because we hear
it we're like oh my God that's how I
feel I just can't word it the way she
can and yet you're a woman which is even
more confusing to me as I was watching
your stuff like how did you learn all
this like why is this your passion so
yeah a little bit about yourself for the
people who haven't seen your content
before yeah so I mean
right I'm a woman who
man who that was never my intention in
life I wasn't young like I want to grow
up to coach men
um I obviously for myself went through a
lot of my own trauma okay and in the
pursuit of discovering how to solve my
own stuff
dove into therapy into self-help courses
trauma therapy Neuroscience things like
that and once I discovered that there
actually is a pathway to Healing trauma
I started posting my video content on
LinkedIn and men were the only ones
reaching out to me so at that point I
realized they didn't have a lot of help
when it came to mental health so I
decided to just be that person because
if there's a group of people in need I
think you should want to be in service
of them if what you have can help and I
think it's kind of natural for us men as
well to feel a warm feeling when a woman
understands us because it's it's very
mothering you know what I mean and it
you put it in a way that's easy for us
to it's gentle it you know you know how
some men's mental health stuff can be is
very like
suck it up buttercup you know whereas
yeah you deliver it in a really easy to
handle way in terms of the men who are
reaching out to you what kind of
demographics are we thinking and also
what are the outcomes that they're
traditionally looking for yeah I have a
very specific demographic for clients
late 30s to Upper 50s men have small
families with a couple of children
they're married and slash or their
marriage is falling apart they're
usually business owners who make a
million plus per year or high up in
management and the pathway is they've
kind of gone along life doing everything
that they're told a man should do and
they've done all the things they've
gotten the job they've gotten the spouse
they've gotten the kids they've worked
overtime they support their family and
then they look up one day and they're
like where's the happy ending where is
the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow their marriage is falling apart
They Don't Really connect well with
their kids you know their spouse is
really angry because maybe they're not
home enough they're not connecting and I
think that's kind of what a lot of men
are feeling like they're like but I did
everything a man is supposed to do so
why am I not getting the happiness from
this I really understand that yeah it
does feel like a thankless job being
that guy and I guess sometimes if you
got into a relationship when you were
young before you really knew who you
were and then you're on the path to
business success and all of that and
before you know it you're evolving as a
person because you're being mixed with
different people making more money and
getting all these experiences and then
you look around one day and you're
talking to that person your partner
realizing if we met now
would we be together absolutely not you
know but we're kind of lumbered together
because we've been stuck together for so
long and we've got these kids together
and all of that so I can I can totally
understand that feeling of Trapped and
pressure and just like running on empty
as a man it definitely feels like you're
on a [__] treadmill way
you're just getting thrown problems to
solve on a daily basis and then there is
no respite there is no relaxation and
this is from like the group chats as
well like my boys even like 24 hours ago
were like my maid put in the group chat
like if there's one thing that gets out
of women's lives it's a man resting I
tell you so how do you go about sort of
tackling that with a guy who feels like
a Pacos who's just there to provide and
serve the family right so I mean you
touched on something very important
which is when we don't take time to know
ourselves we can't possibly partner with
someone who's good for us because at
that point we're just operating off of
some subconscious programming we learned
in childhood which is what I talk a lot
about in my videos and you don't know
that because your brain is so efficient
it just creates a template of survival
when you're young and that's kind of
like what you carry through with you
into adulthood and you don't change it
until something goes wrong
so we kind of have to go back to basics
when it comes to men it's like okay this
is your life right now we can't go back
in time and change it but this is why we
got here and this is how we're going to
fix it moving forward right we have to
start understanding who you are because
chances are you don't know you don't
know who you are you spent your whole
life trying to people please everybody
else to get where you're at and now
you're angry at everybody else because
they're not giving you back anything but
you never really ask for anything in the
first place so we can't spend our whole
lives being angry at the world for you
know not giving us what we didn't ask
for so we kind of have to kind of
reverse engineer starting from where
we're at and then going towards what we
want men who are people Pleasers yeah I
know them I know them very well and
how do they become that way usually do
you think right well people pleasing is
like very general and it's it comes from
the idea that we need to fulfill other
people's needs in order for them to like
us or in order for that person to be
okay so usually it's a sign of growing
up in a dysfunctional family or seeing
dysfunctional relationships where in
order for us to feel safe or for us to
feel loved we just have to change
ourselves to make sure that everything
is calm and okay and if a man has a
single mother the male's not there so he
will then kind of one-up the
people-pleasing
by being the man that she doesn't have
and then that confuses him when he gets
into adult relationships as to what his
role actually is what is it that you
think men are seeking in terms of
Happiness like what what do you think
what do they tell you that makes them
happy they're craving they don't know
what makes them happy right they don't
know what makes them happy at all if
they come to me it's really like a Hail
Mary uh you get them when they're out
there like help me please someone yeah
not in a suicidal or depressed state but
more of like I've kind of tried
everything I've tried the therapy I've
tried the self-help books I've tried to
figure it out and I just can't figure it
out so when they come to me they're kind
of like my life is like this and I
really just want peace or I'd really
just like to feel better about myself
I'd really just like to be more
self-confident I just like this to be
better so obviously for me that's kind
of an easy goal so we get there within
the first couple weeks because really
it's kind of just helping them
understand a little bit more about who
they are and then actually getting them
to understand what does make you happy
yeah in the conversations I have with my
guys it's a lot of it is like respect
peace and gratitude they want their
women to make them feel valued and
appreciated they don't they don't know
what they're asking for because if you
ask them what is respect to you what did
they say I think a lot of the time it's
feeling like they're being listened to
the other person is working with them
not again I'm not competing against them
for power in a relationship you know
that's the level of peace that they're
craving you know I can only assume after
conversations with you where men are
developing their self-confidence and
their self-worth that that could cause
tension and if they're in a marriage
because all of a sudden that woman
potentially may have worked hard to get
everything the way she wants it and all
of a sudden he starts developing other
ideas
I mean have you ever helped someone
who's then developed their self-worth
and then their wife was like yeah [__]
this yeah I mean it definitely happens a
lot but I look at it in a different
perspective right because relationships
take two so if there's one dysfunctional
partner there's two dysfunctional
partners and I know a lot of the kind of
men's coaches out there and stuff look
at women and talk about how toxic they
are and and definitely there are toxic
women like a lot of women are toxic but
when we get in partnership with a toxic
woman we have to address our own you
know reasons why we got there so when
I'm helping them discover themselves and
gain more self-confidence I'm also
trying to help them understand the
communication problems because you know
you can save a marriage that is toxic
if the other person is willing to grow
and sometimes just as much as men don't
feel like they're listened to a lot of
women don't feel like they are listened
to either so when we understand how to
listen we can communicate better how to
get someone to listen to us and it kind
of helps them put down their defenses
and so when I'm working with men I'm on
their side and being on their side means
I also need to be on their partner's
side because I don't want them to lose
everything in their life if they don't
have to I don't want them to see their
partner as an enemy if they don't have
to I want them to find true peace which
is not my partner as the enemy and now I
need to like put up my defenses it's I'm
going to assume my partner means well
and I'm going to try to figure this out
so that we can both be healthy I think
that's the ideal scenario and it for men
sometimes it's just being vulnerable
that's the hard bit it's like I know men
can be scared to let everything out
because well if it's used against me in
an argument and like when I talk to
other men I've actually had men be like
[__] me I've never known another man
speak the way you do about your feelings
because it's just not the done thing it
is scary it's cliche but it is the
ultimate strength isn't it to be as weak
and publicly as possible is is there any
other issues other than vulnerability in
terms of
getting better at communicating as a man
what are the main challenges they face
well exactly like you said they are so
um used to the pattern of grow up grow
some balls men don't cry and so much so
that like you said you're one of the men
who's okay being publicly vulnerable
but a lot of men desire to be vulnerable
and have deep connections with other men
but every time I ask them okay do you
have any friends who you can talk to and
they're like nah my friends aren't like
that but here I am talking to hundreds
of men and they're all saying my friends
aren't like that so men are putting up
this facade to each other that's not
allowing for depth because they're so
afraid that you know not only women are
going to use it against them but men are
also going to use it against them yeah
and also you kind of don't want to be a
burden to the boys like I've definitely
had a lot of problems where I thought I
don't want to bother him with my [__]
you know what I mean I think that's one
of the hardest things about sharing but
yeah like we're always the ones that
when something does go like say if the
worst happens and someone does kill
themselves there's always a group of of
people especially if it's male suicide I
wish I wish he'd spoken to me and that
is definitely something we need to like
make strives to improve in society is
men change and we are changing so fast
like it was like a hundred years ago
where men were just being packed off to
war and just basically slaughtered for
the good of the country and now where
this new version of man out of nowhere
and it's no wonder that we've got a
generation of men who are [__]
confused women are changing in a very
kind of clear way they're becoming more
masculine whereas men are [__]
confused like well what are we then
because we know what user doing we don't
know what the [__] we're supposed to do
because we still feel like manly men a
lot of us but where's our place you know
what I mean it's
it's very difficult for men right now I
totally agree with you that it's it's
super difficult for men to know their
place because when the purpose was for
man to take care of the household and
women to stay at home like the roles
were so clearly defined and now that
women are out working and you know
willing to contribute 50 or whatever it
is it's like I always tell the men who
are in session with me you had this goal
at one point when you were young and it
was like a mountain and to climb that
mountain was like so insane and it kept
you going for like maybe a decade but
then once you got there you're like [__]
I made it but there's no other mountain
right so if a man partners with a woman
and the mountain at one point was
supporting the family and that was a
huge mountain because there's all these
things to take care of and now he
doesn't really have that mountain
anymore it's like it's not as big of a
thing to to work towards like
everybody's losing the desire to work on
themselves because they don't see like
there's not enough payoff right men are
very goal orientated I definitely feel
like I'm at my happy
when I'm almost achieving that goal not
when I'm there but when I'm almost there
that's when I'm like super motivated
excited passionate they're all my best
qualities come out in that moment but
like you say once you get there and you
feel like you've built this life with a
person and then maybe there's other
things that you haven't addressed along
the way because you've just been go goal
orientated that's when you kind of
realize ah this isn't what it was
supposed to be and I think a lot of men
not and again I'm not this discounting
women's feelings but obviously this is a
men's mental health podcast a lot of men
do get to that place where they think
this is supposed to be the dream but I
don't feel like that right and not that
like we all know like happiness is a
temporary emotion but what I'm talking
about is that peace and that Tranquility
that men have worked really hard to
build into a life and then yeah they get
there and it's that's where the
confusion starts creeping in you
mentioned gender roles and biology and
all of that right now because that is I
think part of where men are struggling
as well and knowing their their place
because we are trying this sort of uh
shoehorn
um ourselves into a new role in society
meanwhile men and women are still kind
of biologically built the way we always
have been so there are some things where
Society is changing but we're not
changing we're still it takes millions
of years to evolve and stuff like that
so women still look for a provider
hunter-gatherer whatever you want to
call it and men still are looking for a
nurturer but women are becoming more
masculine so men I think are a little
bit in a con state of confusion as to
well what is our role then and have you
have you found that
um those issues coming are coming out in
some of your conversations with men or
no yeah in the way that you had brought
up earlier where there's just a lot of
conflict in in relationships because
when you have two masculine energies
right conflict is bound to come up and
so when the man is trying to be kind of
like the dominant energy is trying to
lead right dominant as in he's trying to
lead but then the woman is also trying
to lead because she doesn't want her
independence to be taken away in
relationship right there's just constant
conflict all the time that's where you
get those Petty fights that's and so
that's where it comes out I think
because we're already caught up in the
relationships and the marriages and in
the dating World they don't even commit
to each other in a relationship anymore
now it's kind of like you know the
Andrew tateway of life where people are
just jumping around no commitment seeing
people as just things to toss aside you
know and and they are they're not
putting any value on the family unit
anymore they're not putting any value on
roles anymore they're just kind of
wandering about yeah I've definitely
seen that in a big way and I feel like
women women on men are very confused in
this point because women have been sold
the dream a little bit of like you will
be independent but I don't think anyone
really explained that that doesn't mean
you'll be happy like to me when I say
women out there happiest as when they
are in a family unit or when they're in
a relationship where they feel loved and
adored and all of that and they feel
taken care of protected like all of this
has been and I look I might be
triggering people or whatever but I feel
like they've been sold this like
feminist dream of like well this is what
strength is strength is masculinity
that's what the ironically in demonizing
men what you're actually selling is
masculinity is strength but femininity
is strong in its own right it's just
different and that a woman who's a
mother who takes care of her kids who
can be a lioness in our own right but
also it doesn't mean you have to
challenge the man at every step and
problem is as men are built feel like
again biologically this isn't like in my
opinion we are built want to guide a
family and to be the provider and
therefore if I'm bringing in the bacon I
should always be the one who has final
say
um in regards to the serious stuff not
the little trivial stuff and once that
gets challenged and challenged and
challenged men in my experience who I
know in relationships and this is across
the board I'm talking hundreds of guys I
know just feel like they're in
relationships where if anything women
are wearing the pants a lot more than
men now like by you know a high
percentage are you phoning that too
women women wearing the pants and with
the guy I mean obviously you're dealing
with high rollers but yeah but it's not
even necessarily that women are like
wearing the pants it's just that men
don't know where to go when they're
being challenged because they don't want
to upset their partner because generally
men are lovers men love to love their
women right men don't want to cause harm
even though they're capable of it and so
when you're in a relationship where
they're in love and they want to lead
but they don't want to they don't want
to have conflict so they're kind of
trying to just please their woman but in
doing so they become the people pleaser
they become the Yes Man and then that
Stacks and stacks and stacks to a point
where he's in a box where he's like oh
my God I literally can't make any
decisions because she's going to get
pissed off and I don't want to piss her
off and he just ends up moving out of
the bedroom and they have a roommate
situation for the next 15 years so it's
kind of like teaching them how to stand
in their boundaries and that it's
actually okay to have a little bit of
conflict in a relationship as long as
there's healthy repair and kind of
helping our partner understand that
we're working together and let's say if
you're in a relationship you know you
would want your partner to work with you
not you're not your idea of leadership
isn't just like okay this is what we're
doing no questions asked don't talk to
me about it you're deciding together but
like you have a mission you have a
vision and you want to align with a
person who's like I want to do that too
like let's build big things let's do it
together yeah and I've been coming to
this sort of feeling that for those men
they want to please their women so they
think if I say yes and this is how
complicated women are no offense but if
I say yes I will make her happy and like
to an extent I understand the logic in
that but women actually I do think or
build to challenge a man's Authority
to
um as in to challenge him as masculinity
um to test him are you a suitable mate
are you how strong are you and in doing
in standing your ground with respect and
doing it at the right time when you are
maybe in the right it can build
something stronger where she will
respect you more and therefore value
um your opinion your you know you will
gain ground but in a healthy way you
just have to be willing to withstand
that moment of difficulty but it will
actually send you down a much better
path as a relationship and the amount of
men who miss that opportunity early on
and I see them later on where they're
like taking their wife's name up the
aisle practically you know what I mean
like she you know they might as well be
throwing the bouquet over their shoulder
like you know and I'm like bro if you
just stood your ground a little more at
the right moments you'd feel so much
better about yourself she would respect
you more and
um you know do you think I'm off base
with that or because I'm just bro
silencing this to be honest with you no
you're actually I mean for as correct as
we could be right like we're kind of
making all of this up masculine feminine
energy but there's actually a book
called The Way of the superior man and
he talks about this in the book How The
Feminine and this is true because like
if you think about a soul mate it's kind
of like your soulmate isn't exactly
everything that you are you're opposite
in some ways and they're meant to
challenge you and you kind of like the
challenge because you're seeing the
world through a different lens and so
the masculine seeks out like the strong
masculine seeks out uh the divine
feminine who can challenge him and push
all his buttons because if those buttons
aren't pushed how does he truly know
himself how does he truly know his own
strength and know how to stand in his
own power if it's never challenged yeah
and it is fascinating to sort of almost
remove men and women from this and talk
about masculine and feminine energy
because everything is so different in
2023 and you do find a lot of women who
are the more masculine in a relationship
and men who are the more
agreeable and softer energy and like I
say those guys as a manly man and not
that I'm like I look I'm very agreeable
when when it's time to be agreeable you
know you want a successful relationship
but sometimes I do want to give them a
shake and go [__] helmet stand up do
you know what I mean it'll actually do
you uh the world of good and you were
talking about something before about
when you're having how arguments can be
healthy what is it like a sort of a
healthy level of arguing and also
repairing that because that's something
I've struggled with where if I have an
argument with someone
and I feel like they've dragged it out
too long because I'm the type of person
if I'm in an argument with a woman and I
know she's right and I'm very I've got a
lot of humility actually compared for a
guy who talks on camera and probably
people think as an ego I will
immediately go I'm sorry I'm wrong
you're right I'm sorry because my mother
taught me that of like just say sorry as
soon as you're wrong and it's it's over
do you know what I mean and you can move
on but women women don't like saying
sorry to me in my life I don't know if
I've just met the wrong women but I it's
it's like a grind to get a sorry like
you have to keep going over everything
and then they change the subject and
then before you know and and I'm like I
don't know if it's today's generation of
women that are like that but I I I'm
like it can't just be me experiencing
this because I've dated a lot of women a
lot right and this is a common thing in
modern women where I find it very easy
to apologize and I have to almost grind
them down and by by the time I get the
sorry I'm like was that even [__]
worth it you know and that's the point
where I start really doubting the whole
point in the relationship where I'm like
just to get a sorry out of you I've got
to draw blood from a stone here
um and that's where I have like days
after the argument where I'm not I'm not
holding a grudge I'm not I'm not being
childish in slamming doors or anything
or giving them silent treatment but
within myself I feel wounded I'm like
this is this has been a hell of a week
um sorry I just blew all that out but
yes
um no that's perfect yeah and what
you're experiencing is what I think a
lot of men experience and you know this
is all a lot due to the fact that we're
not really taught the important things
about relationships in life like how do
we repair after an argument how do we
have a healthy argument and healthy
disagreement is okay it's not screaming
it's not shouting at each other it's
saying can I understand your perspective
and can you understand my perspective
and I would totally agree with you that
a lot of women will kind of circle
around and circle around and circle
around and a lot of men actually do this
too and it's a sign of somebody who
doesn't want to take accountability for
their actions like you said you have a
lot of humility someone who doesn't want
to take accountability wants to circle
around because they want to absolve
themselves of a guilt of hurting you and
so they will circle around circle around
all the reasons why why you did this so
that's why I did what I did and then I'm
gonna Tire you out so then eventually
maybe you'll apologize to me again
because I feel so guilty about what I've
done wrong like they don't want to take
accountability and that's actually a
character trait you you'd want to avoid
from someone because people generally
don't change that until they wake up
right so like I would say yes you have
maybe you've dated a lot of women sounds
like a lot of the wrong women yeah um
but a lot of people don't understand how
to repair and one thing I would say
about the apologies that you kind of
learned just saying I'm sorry
doesn't mean it's done oh no because the
formula for um good apology and this is
what my therapist taught me sorry if I
get it not 100 correct you have to make
sure the other person feels understood
so like you acknowledge what happened
make them feel understood uh like
repeating back what they've said and
then actually apologize and then say an
action for what you're going to do to
change the behavior that hurt them
because without action there's no true
apology right the greatest apology is
change Behavior so what a lot of women I
think and this is like a separate but a
lot of women will kind of bring up the
same topic again and again and again and
it pisses me off because you're like I
said sorry it should be over right done
left it in the past but she's not seeing
the behavior change so she's bringing it
up again and again and again and nothing
is changing because the apology hasn't
actually been an apology it's just been
something to absolve the argument for
the moment so just a recap there you
give your an apology you explain why you
are sorry why they were how they were
feeling and that you completely
understand where you went wrong and then
you say and in future here is how I'm
gonna improve on my issue and I think
also one of the tricks that I've learned
in terms of just arguing in a the nicest
way disagreeing in the next way
is for me I sometimes drop things in and
I go look I might put my hand on their
hand and just go I'm on your side here
I'm I'm not I love you I care about you
I'm not trying to you know be difficult
but this has really hurt my feelings and
and the tone of ice and little things
like that can pour cold water on a
situation
so quickly it's those little bitey
things that we do when we're sort of and
it is very animalistic isn't it like
nipping at each other they're the things
that can turn a minor disagreement major
out of nowhere those little nasty little
comments yeah because all of a sudden
you're like you're bringing something up
from three months ago and then you get
freaking Biz you're like you always
bring this up and yeah that's where men
are the most sensitive as well in terms
of like if a woman knows there's a red
button and she continues to push it that
can I don't know if women are the same
but I feel for men if we have that thing
and they keep bringing that thing up it
can destroy you so like over time it can
be that real weak spot that they just
keep punching and punching and punching
before you know it you're like
mentally can't take that anymore so yeah
I I think the skill of arguing like um a
guy I had on my podcast recently said
like arguments can be the salt and
pepper on a relationship it can help the
relationship if Done Right but it's it's
this generation I feel where we're not
really taught to do that properly
because so many people come from broken
homes now like so yeah so I would say
every generation was never taught how to
argue correctly because before it was
just like shut up or I'll slap you you
know like there was no healthy argument
and then we're coming from that
generation yeah you know and then we're
coming out of you know just man up don't
say anything you know like so now men
are taught to be quiet about their
feelings right it's kind of like the the
mental slap of like just shut up oh I
think women also play on the power so
men obviously like in my great Granddad
Zera for example it was a it was a
threat of violence I suppose back in
that era or the potential of it because
that was the old school and now
men feel the opposite where some aims I
guess in in couples and relationships I
know where men have told me almost that
they feel the women know that they have
so much power in the event that a man
does anything physical that they can all
they almost men are almost like oh like
I'm being guarded what do I do and they
just shut down because they're being
do you understand what I mean like where
women are aware of like I push your
buttons you can't touch me yes and
therefore to the point where the women
uh physically abuse the men and they
can't say anything because even and I
I've had clients who have this
experience they've gone to you know
they've tried to get help and they're
basically like laughed at it's really
sad actually and then they're stuck in
this situation they're in and this is
you know deep if they have kids and
they're married they're stuck in the
situation they're in because then if
they try to leave then they're you know
have to pay alimony they lose their kids
or sometimes the woman will use the kids
as a tool to you know if you leave me
I'm going to take the kids away or you
know I've never heard of a divorce where
that hasn't been said right you know
like every woman pretty much well
unfortunately the majority will use that
against them on and I've actually known
a man who's been like beaten up by his
girlfriend before right it's a lot
actually he's like ringing the cops and
you're like
[__] hell do you do bro and and they
won't do anything but they call them
yeah because because the level of damage
isn't as severe as when a man does it
it's a lot and even took to be
absolutely respectful the female victims
out there it's not good enough for them
either but I'm you know what I'm saying
like with men it's a real gray area
where people just never take it
seriously have you experienced that with
a man where like how did that work out
for him did he did he get out of that
situation really a lot of them are still
in it um I have you look good when you
said that what you looked
oh he's still in it yeah yeah I mean
because it's really sad because I what
can I do right because you know I
sometimes I feel really bad because you
know and you get so many messages I'm
sure from people who are struggling and
in help and
and you can't necessarily do anything
but watch and so that's why you know you
have to make the video content to hope
that some little piece of advice can
help people get the inner strength to
know what's next for their life path but
we can't just
slide it under the carpet that female
abuse to men is okay just because it
doesn't leave as big a mark right
because teaching abuse to your children
or to like men and it's just not healthy
it's not healthy yeah I yeah I knew a
woman once who told me her her fella hit
her and I I'd known them previous like
for a while and I thought that's a
really nice guy
I'm really surprised that he would do
that to you and I know you're crazy
because I'd seen her previous
relationships where she'd been you know
a nightmare and I was like well did you
hit him first and she was like well yeah
but he's still a wife beer and I was
like
that's the way it works you know what I
mean like for a lot of these for a lot
of these relationships for men where
you're at a mage at this Advantage
legally it feels like and that's there's
a lot of men who are living in fear and
I knew one guy who he would come home
from work and he would take sleeping
pills early on in the night so that he
could avoid like contact with her and
just like go to sleep early
um the things men do in abusive
relationships usually are
self-destructive they're absolutely do
you think absolutely they will
um you know they'll go home after work
and they'll have to have a drink just to
calm down just to stop the racing
thoughts they don't sleep through the
night they get anxiety medication they
get depression medication they get the
sleeping pills
they just numb themselves out to life
because they don't know what to do
there's no happiness there's no way out
if you have kids that's the only thing
you're really living for even though you
don't really connect with them because
you're so zonked out it's really sad it
feels like men and women react to
difficult relationships in different
ways so like
judging by statistically anyway
women will leave when they are really
unhappy I think eighty percent of
divorces are initiated by women whereas
men men will just like slowly destroy
themselves while cheating like or
something like that you know like and
it's just funny that men get this tag of
being cheats
and but women really kind of don't have
any label for what they're parting and
like let's be real I'm I'm not saying
that it's all men's fault or all women's
fault I would say this because Society
supports women just so much more than it
supports men so women have their girls
to go talk to they're okay going to a
therapist they're okay going to the
forums and looking up I'm unhappy
whatever and men don't have anyone to go
to so they're not talking to Jim about
their problems they're going home and
and drinking gym right you know they're
like let's see your point about Society
if if you have a child and you have an
issue women will be taken in uh in the
UK anyway Council house you got you get
rehoused men there's the streets right
so it's you know there's no sympathy
you're right there's no empathy so it's
not necessarily that because I do
believe that women take a long time to
make that decision and they're trying to
speak to the men and trying to speak to
the the husbands you know we're just
taking out the abusive and toxic people
right like yeah we're talking about
average relations average relationships
people are trying to make things work
and the the problem that we have this is
what I see so much is because men are
taught not to feel their feelings from a
very young age they disconnect from
themselves and they disconnect from
their deep wants needs and desires they
don't know how to communicate it Etc so
when a woman is trying to repair the
relationship and this is all freaking
new to him and he thinks it's a
tolerable level of unhappiness that
she's complaining about he will minimize
the problem and it's not just about him
taking the trash out it's not just about
him cleaning the gutters or whatever
she's complaining about over and over
again that he zonks out of his mind
she's trying to connect with him in a
way that says like we need to work on
things and it doesn't register in his
mind until she's like out and by that
time she's like I've tried for so many
years and this happens with men too men
do the exact same thing they've tried
for years they've gotten the therapy
they've gotten the self-help and the
woman is like so angry and she doesn't
do anything until the very last second
so it's kind of like why are we
minimizing our partners problems if
they're bringing it up to us it's big
for them I think they're also more
self-aware in their emotions right
because in my experience I was raised by
a woman it became apparent to me from a
young age that women question am I happy
about every hour you know they're always
wondering like am I happy am I happy if
I'm not why am I not like it's in their
mind a lot whereas men we're trying to
just get [__] done we're not we're not
considering our we're like I'll be happy
in 20 years am I being productive yeah
yeah am I getting it done yeah like like
a dog almost like you know you give us
something to chase after a ball a catch
and we feel great you know where women
are probably a bit more philosophical
about their happiness than men are and
you know credit do them and I think
that's the that's where the Clash often
comes is we just think about things so
differently we value things so
differently
and I think that's where the frustration
from women's side often comes is like
how do you not understand me you know
and it's like we don't even value the
same things in a relationship men women
are looking at status men are looking at
Beauty you know like and I think it's
such a difficult thing to
unlock in a relationship is that like I
seen a guy who did this diagram once of
how men communicate versus how women
communicate and he drew like a man say
says to the guy he's like you want to
meet up at six o'clock yeah no problem
I'll see you at this place yeah okay
I'll be there then and it was a straight
line and he goes women's conversations
uh what do you fancy doing tonight I
don't know I've been doing my hair um I
might I might go out I don't know my
makeup my eyelashes like it's just all
over the place and he said men and women
but what he meant was like feminine
versus masculine styles of communication
are just so different men are very
direct women are a lot more all over the
place and I think that's part of the
issue for us is just try trying to be
more patient men are quite impatient
with our communication we want we want
the answer why the [__] aren't you happy
let me sort it give me a problem to fix
and then she gives you a paragraph
paragraph long thing and you're like I
don't want to read this paragraph So you
respond to one little tidbit and then
she gets really pissed off because she's
trying to explain to you but that's not
the way you register right well then we
trivialize the paragraph I guess because
we're like right this is long right yeah
and uh you know what she wants isn't as
a paragraph long response because that's
how she's going to feel like you
understood what she's saying but you
don't want to do that because you're
like a plus b equals c the amount of
text messages I've gotten from women
where it's like that and yeah and and
just seeing the big chunky paragraph
come up I'm like
[__] Health here we go you know what
I mean like this is it's like an essay
of all the things I'm not doing right or
whatever and I respect like women have
their right to say that but again it's
just how men digest things we're just
not able to cope that way right and you
know I think when it comes to that uh a
really good solution like what you kind
of mentioned when it comes to repair is
like save conversations like that for in
person
um
next to man a paragraph he doesn't want
to read it it's too overwhelming it's so
true like too much too much for here and
so much better when you can you can sit
in a room and you have the tone of voice
and you can hold hands or hug or
whatever and you you just I think and
you can tell me if I'm right or wrong
but I think men will absorb what you're
saying so much better when it's spoken
to you and like you know you're in the
room as opposed to like you have to read
it and try to understand it yeah I don't
I know that we all have our love
languages and I think for me if a woman
like is just like putting her arm up
your shoulder and just talk like talking
to you in a softer way how you package
it I know we have that old saying of the
[__] sandwich you know like you do this
really well but here's the things you
need to work on
they do it does help yeah and I think
sometimes because and look I understand
I've been trying to understand women a
lot better as I get older and I think
there's a lot of frustrated women out
there who are just one meant to be a bit
more competent and and things like that
that when men are screw-ups who don't
keep their word who don't do what they
say they were going to do that's where
that tone of voice just gets worn out
and eventually they're like the [__]
this and at that point in truthfully
told women should really know you're
already done with them like when you're
at that point yeah of course because
you're a very competent woman and you
will be able to figure out a man's
incompetency very quickly I'm sure but
for a lot of women they keep batting the
door and kicking and kicking and hoping
that for a change it ain't coming and
that's where you get like 30 years down
the road and you're miserable and
arguing with each other well I lied
weaving yeah well because not neither
you had the balls to walk out at the
right time time but what was it like
when you were there tell me if you don't
mind me asking I mean you know it's just
it's one of those things where you get
together and you really love each other
and then
you know for for our specific
relationship we had something traumatic
happen and he kind of had checked out I
was a men's coach at this time I just
started but I had learned all these
things and I was trying my best to apply
all of the tactics I knew and this is
why I bring this relationship up because
sometimes you can have the whole
Encyclopedia of tips and tricks and you
know how to be the feminine the
masculine and you're like encouraging
and respectful and whatever and it it
doesn't fix the relationship because
ultimately it's two different people who
have to find their own paths right
um but when I was in it you know it was
I I looked around and I was like dude
how did I get here because I did start
nitpicking at like he said he was gonna
do the dishes and he literally didn't do
the dishes and it was like but
everything was like that and and for me
it was just so frustrating because it
wasn't even about the dishes it was just
the fact that he never did what he said
he was gonna do and I'm such a person
who that is so important to me because I
do what I say I'm gonna do
and so when you don't do it I feel like
you're lying to me and if you're lying
to me like where's the where's the
connection right and like women are so
intuitive so it's like it really makes
us angry when we feel like you know we
can tell that you're not being straight
with us
right and we want to know why and then
we start nitpicking we get angry because
then we feel like all of the
responsibility is on us and I'm like I
don't need another son I mean another
son I don't have a son in the first time
I don't need a son yeah you know I want
a partner and I want I want you to be
the strong one I want you to lead I
don't want to wear the pants and I would
get frustrated I'd be like I I don't
want to do women find themselves wearing
the pants for men who aren't men like as
in grown men right yeah who are still in
that teenage boy phase of their life and
that's why women will stay up in age all
the time because they want a man who's
ready in there and yeah I totally
understand that like and one of the one
of my favorite quotes of yours was about
integrity and by the weakest quality in
a man in in their opinion when you've
dealt with them is it is that right is
that right I mean that was that's
probably my opinion is a man who lacks
integrity
you know he he falls apart on himself
because he doesn't when you don't do
what you say you're gonna do you stop
trusting yourself and when you stop
trusting yourself you start to turn on
everyone around you start to be passive
aggressive you start to take on the
victim mentality like you start blaming
the world for why you're not where
you're at when really it's it's the fact
that you you didn't get up and work out
this morning like you said you were
going to you didn't study for the exam
like you said you were going to you're
like oh the exam was too hard was going
to fail it anyway you take on the loser
mentality and it makes you weak honestly
there are weak men in the world and
there are weak women in the world we
can't just say everybody's a winner like
when you start lying to yourself you've
adopted the mindset of a liar and then
you you just fall to the bottom of the
pit and I don't want anybody who I'm
coaching to take on so I pointed out to
them immediately like you said you were
going to do this they feel embarrassed
to me if they don't do like the action
items because there's no reason not to
I've dealt with people like that before
and it's it's really frustrating and
it's sad actually
because it's it's a bit pathetic as well
especially from when you're wanting to
see a man fulfill their full potential
like I've known people who have all the
potential in the world but they can't do
[__] they can't keep their word it's
often the most gifted people in terms of
pretending to be something else like
they pull the wall over everyone's eyes
but there's someone like me I say
straight [__] through it and and I
start pointing out you know what I mean
like you said this you didn't do this
classic problem every [__] time and
you're right like it the passive
aggressive the poor pitiful me comes out
and it's so you just want to give them a
[__] shake and be like come on you're
better than this you have so much talent
and ability and yet you're letting
yourself just waste it because you just
can't even deliver and uh yeah that is
for a man I think it's a worse quality
because it just it's so obvious in men
when they like that because men
traditionally aren't supposed to be that
guy well if you're talking about men
naturally being the leaders
leaders don't not do what they say
they're going to do so and listen this
is a pattern that I see you know we were
talking about red pill and Andrew Tate
and all these followers right it's
always the men who are like I want a
submissive woman I want this I want that
who are not doing what they say they're
going to do they're not they're not
actually achieving enough because the
men who are like actually really truly
doing what they say they're going to
they naturally have women who who
respect them and follow them because
they respect themselves it's a
self-respect thing and you don't respect
yourself you're going to demand that
everybody else respect you first
this is the thing about the Andrew thing
and you know I've had many issues with
him and the truth is the main reason why
he doesn't like me was because of my
first ever video I seen him when he had
barely any followers I said I'm getting
all Cali vibes from this guy just
immediately and ironically R Kelly was
found guilty of trafficking right yeah
because he looks for the most weakest
vulnerable people because real strong
men they don't resort to getting young
vulnerable women to take their clothes
off for money to actually earn a living
for them and everyone's looking at him
thinking this guy is the true definition
of masculinity he [__] all these women
it's like you know who the real
masculine men are [__] like the
firemen who goes to graft every day
comes home puts their [__] food on
the table for his family and is
um faithful of his wife and lives like a
man should live that is not a man to me
like and um I don't respect them in in
the slightest
um so that's who I think young men
should actually be looking at is like
there's a guy I grew up with
um bricklayer you know Bill is a
beautiful home for his wife devoted to
his family puts the work in every day
and you know you can see some days his
wife's chewing his ear off or you know
but he just gets on with it and he he
he's built a family and I respect and
the older I get you know when I was in
my 20s when the money came I just bought
all these cars and I was shagging the
girls and all of that right but the
hitting your thing is you start to
realize like that's [__] like being
a family man is the true definition of
like masculinity and
um that's what I really respect now
because it isn't easy to do that it's
actually easy when you have a bit of
status and money to get a load of these
young women interested in you and go and
shag them but it's there's nothing
meaningful about it and as Jordan
Peterson said on a clip I watched the
other day where he goes you know if
you're a man and you can have sex with a
hundred women okay
you can do that it's going to be really
something and it is something to have a
lot of women interested in you but I
after that are you going to feel like
you're meaningful yourself when you've
had casual sex with all those women
there is no way you yourself as a man
can feel meaningful when you've just
given it away to everyone there's
nothing special about that and the only
men who really look up to that are the
ones they've never experienced it well I
have and I'm telling you it's nothing
it's not all it's cracked up to be
um I'm sorry I'm just ranting right now
but you know no I love it there is
nothing that compares to being in love
with a woman to being dedicated to her
and being completely like I am going to
work my ass off to give you the best in
life and that we are going to build
something together all of them women
that I've had sex with before like
meeting a good woman I'd get rid of them
in a heartbeat to be with her the whole
time now do you know what I mean like
that's how I feel about it so I think a
lot of these young impressionable men
you're being sold the dreamlots and it's
a load of [__] stop uh chasing this
these courses that are going to teach
how to trick women ability to strip on a
webcam for you it's insane dude I love
every single thing about what you just
said and I think like literally what you
just said right now is like every girl's
like dream of like oh my God I want that
kind of man right because so many women
are taught you know lock it up don't
give yourself away well now the thing is
like go have casual sex whatever but you
know I grew up in the Midwest of the
United States so like religious belt and
uh really um I mean my family wasn't
religious but this is what I was
surrounded by so it was kind of like if
you have sex you're a [__] right like
that is the thing you know like Mean
Girls you will have sex and get pregnant
and die and so
um you know that's something that I've
kind of carried with me throughout life
is like you know you have intimacy with
someone special like in the midwest you
date to marry you don't date to date
around like when I turn to 18 I moved to
California it was such a culture shock
for me because people like dated
multiple people at a time you didn't
just like go out with someone because
you liked him and you wanted to be
boyfriend girlfriend I was so confused I
was single and so a little bit for all
five years that I lived there wow
because I would I just didn't get it
that wasn't me maybe
part of the issue for these young men as
well is though is the way women are
presenting to men like this culture that
we're in as much as I'm telling men that
that's not the way to go
they're also meeting women who aren't
behaving in that way of wife me up I am
your partner in life I am going to add
value to your life a lot of them don't
understand what that even means to a man
because they again think we think like
they think like we think that you may be
earning however much money you earn or
whatever is going to make us happier
which a lot of the time that's not
really what men are looking like they're
looking at for you to talk to us in a
way that makes us feel elevated and
treat us like a king or by that I just
mean make us a sandwich do you know like
little things the tiniest little things
can make a man feel like oh well that
was lovely like we're so easily pleased
really whereas women are out here I
think and they have to like build an
Empire we want to be a power couple but
a lot of the time men don't I don't
think they think like that right and
that's the thing that's exactly like you
said women are being sold this dream
that be the you know entrepreneur and
get your bag and like it's totally I
think it's good to do that right I think
you should want to be successful and you
should want to follow your dreams and
expand but to think that that's part of
what makes a healthy masculine feminine
relationship because a lot of men that I
talk to they really don't care about
that and it kind of gets in the way of
him connecting with her because she's
all talking about building a business
and he's like I don't really care about
that because I've built my business
exactly right especially like the
high-earning men yeah like women are
being fed to be masculine in all facets
so go get money go get a job go get the
bag also have your sexual Freedom sleep
with whoever you want right and then men
are now kind of I think going a little
bit away from that because
um and I think that they should and I
made a post one time that men should
practice being chased they should
practice not having sex when in
relationships until they actually think
that they want to be with someone long
term because what's the point like you
said when you have sex with so many
people you are just decreasing your own
values
you can just buy me at poundland right
like literally like it's like why would
anybody like have your sexual freedom
but is sexual Freedom really like worth
it when it's with so many people have it
with one person have it with someone
special make it deep not wide or even I
would recommend even just rushing
yourself to a level where you're like
okay
do I see potential in this right if so
then yeah but with me obviously like
when I first got attention on a level
that I did again how could I ever have
distinguished between a good quality
woman and a not and and an average woman
and a low average woman who in terms of
how they were going to treat me when
they were there were so many of them and
I was treating them all the same I
couldn't differentiate so that that was
a really bad bad idea
um and it really confused me and
actually it only improved where I got to
a moment where
um I hurt someone's feelings and I
realized you know what I'm not treating
people the way I should be treating here
and I made a decision to just go
no more I'm not going to talk to any I'm
going to talk to like one woman at a
time and I'm not gonna be being this
person that I've been because if you
continue doing what you've always done
you're going to get the results you've
always got so I have to change something
here and that is something that I think
men scientifically can kind of get with
and immediately I met a great person
immediately like it was within a couple
of months you know what I mean of
changing my whole idealism of how I view
women how I talk to women and just being
like and also like so for men normally
we're very cagey in regards to what we
want how uh you know in terms of
commitment and stuff like that whereas I
went all right let me be a bit more
proactive and be like here's who I am
and and tell no secret keep no secrets
so before I've been like aloof and you
don't want to give anything away
especially when you've got a bit of
public eye on you whereas that this time
I was like I'm gonna tell you everything
and leave and literally no secrets and
it took the risk of like being judged
harshly or them thinking whatever about
me and if anything I think as you said
about women women can tell when you're
not given the full picture and if
anything it made her go oh
I'm gonna be really respectful of the
fact that you've told me everything even
the stuff I don't want to know and I'm
actually going to have more respect for
you now because you are being your true
authentic self and I know guys
who have been with their women for years
who I will have a conversation with
and and they will say things oh I
wouldn't say that in front of my life
and I'm like bro if she what's the point
she's supposed to be like your your best
person in the whole [__] world you're
telling me she basically doesn't even
know the real you because if you can say
something to me then how the [__] can
you not say it in front of the person
you sleep with you you have [__]
breakfast with every morning like they
should know everything they need to know
about you
um and I think that that level of
intimacy that you can create through
water and all everything good and bad is
actually sets a tone for a relationship
where then the woman also feels like
okay you're not gonna judge me then and
I can be and for men out there the best
sex comes when the woman isn't you know
worried about being judged and she's
like you just take me for everything
that's beautiful 100 I I agree with
everything you just said and I have so
many men come to me too and they're like
you're the first person I've ever told
these things to after like you know
being with someone for like 20 years
like they just they don't feel like they
can talk and so many people in my
comment section and I'm sure in your
comment section too are like you yeah
well men can't express themselves
because a woman's just going to use it
against them or she'll leave you and I'm
like why would you be with someone who
is going to leave you for expressing
yourself what is the point of being in a
relationship what did you think the
point of being in a relationship was are
you just seeing yourself as a genetic
machine where you're just passing
Offspring on because being in
relationship with someone eating
breakfast with someone sleeping with
someone doing everything with someone
their family your family
every day for the rest of your life
and you can't express yourself there's a
flaw in that and it's not just with I
mean it's with women for using it
against you yes but also why would you
want to choose that life it's time that
we take we because all we can do is take
accountability all we can do is take it
on and say
I want to express myself here I am and
that gives you so much respect because
then she goes he's not hiding from
himself so I don't have to pull himself
out of him because I can see you without
you telling me yes and I want you to
admit who you are because then we can
both start from ground zero right so I'm
not hiding myself you're not hiding
yourself
let's go it's so much healthier and and
it look men are a victim of Their Own
Strength sometimes because it is amazing
what some men can bottle up and walk
around with on their shoulders every
[__] day and and and act like
everything's fine when in reality this
is why male suicide is obviously the way
it is because the curry and Curry and
Curry until they explode one day but I
can honestly say hand on heart as
someone who lived a life like that where
I was the burden of so many other
people's difficulties in providing and
caring for so many people that the
minute I allow that to just go
I became so much happier and
um
the guilt of and the shame of of the way
I'd felt previously of things I was
hiding things that weren't even bad but
like you know just not feeling like I've
been my true self when men come to you
in terms of things like guilt and shame
and I think shame and guilt is like the
number one thing men carry around on
their back for like no reason they just
they feel ashamed of just who they are
for just being for having problems for
feeling sad for being upset they just
want to be totally absent and void of
the emotion men do not like to feel
these things and they come to me and
they're like I don't want to feel like
this I'm like okay well you have to uh
at least for a second because the whole
reason you're you know feeling it so
strong is because you continue to avoid
it and
um you know when it comes to things like
cheating and things like that you know
we all get to places in our lives where
we make decisions based upon what we
think is best in the moment and
sometimes uh you know like you said I
made a video on this men don't know what
to do sometimes and they don't know how
to get out of things sometimes and they
will subconsciously
do something impactful and wrong in a
relationship so that it gives them an
excuse or it gives their partner an
excuse to just blow up their life yep
you know just to restart reset button
because they don't want to say I don't
want to do this anymore because it's so
hard if there's nothing really wrong you
know if there is no abuse there's no
alcoholism there's because like you said
men stay through that when they get to a
point where they just can't take it
anymore internally and they just don't
know what to do they don't know how to
connect with that feeling they will blow
it up subconsciously by cheating I've
definitely been there before where I've
just thought like
I don't care about the consequences
anymore I don't value life like I don't
care about anything I'm not I'm not
enjoying any of anything anymore do you
know what I mean so I'm going to get my
small little amounts of pleasure
wherever I can and just live like that
you know what I mean and
um when so so there's like different
levels of this right but if a man is in
a toxic abusive relationship or he's in
a relationship which is constantly never
appreciates him never respects him never
loves him and he finds someone who gives
them a little bit of attention you know
he goes for it he absolutely goes for it
and then creates this fantasy fictional
world of like this is going to be so
much different with this girl but hasn't
done any work on himself So eventually
she does turn into the wife as well if
he gets with her but it's just one of
those things where we like we look for
the Escape instead of look for the
solution that's a real male problem for
sure like
um and I've I've seen that before where
a man has gone to another woman like as
you say you're in a nagging relationship
and then he goes to another woman and
that other woman then turns into the
nagging woman too because he is still a
problem and it is it's hilarious because
he's like say I knew she was the issue
and then three months later this new
woman's also nagging
um but equally Sometimes women don't
realize how
in the marketplace
um as a man is entering into his 30s and
gaining in status and money and all of
that and also maturing into a man and
not that incompetent boy that these
girls in their 20s are struggling with
his value is rising whereas a woman
because I guess a woman's value is often
based on beauty age yada yada
um their value is decreasing and and you
know in a sense in the marketplace not
always but you know do you understand
what I mean of it like um yeah and I
always look at like relationships like
that and I'm like girl you better get a
ring on that finger as quick as you can
because if you guys split up it's
difficult I was just going to ask you
about that um because I thought you were
talking about like married men and then
kind of like she's you know whatever not
aging well and he's getting more and
more successful but you're talking about
the relationships where they've been
together for maybe like five six seven
years and you're still not married
that's more common now I was gonna ask
you about that because you're a man and
there's this the theory that like men
know right away pretty much where they
see a woman and you know depending on
their own Readiness and things like that
but if he's with someone for three four
five six seven years and hasn't proposed
like chancar he doesn't see her as the
one she's kind of like the the Gap
girlfriend because then right after they
break up he gets married to the next
person okay this is a really good topic
because this is happening a lot I know
people like this I could never uh I
write so in my experience the man I know
that I've done that have have sometimes
closed the deal after six seven years
but in that time they are keeping their
options open because they in their heart
of hearts are holding out a belief that
I still might be able to do better than
you so let me just keep you on ice and
if nothing better comes along then we'll
close the deal
and a lot of men I know actually will
propose to a girl to give the illusion
of commitment to make her think like
yeah this is going somewhere and we'll
have what we call a long engagement and
there'll always be a reason why in this
longing oh we're not quite there yet
we're still saving for a house
but in reality he knows that that
engagement ring until you confirm the
wedding means nothing and that they're
sort of putting it as a placeholder
they're right I'll keep you on ice and a
lot of men like if this was showing the
men and women out there how they deny it
but I'm [__] right and I know I'm
right because as you said because think
about it logically like and look I'm
going to compare it to buying things
because men are very like that right you
know and women on possessions but in our
eyes when we're in the you know the
marketplace we're looking for the best
possible thing for us just as women are
we're no different if you feel like you
got the deal of the century you can't
get it through the till quick enough
right because you don't want someone
else to buy it no because he you a man
knows that if you're not married you're
still in the marketplace too and so if
he's not locking it down it's not
bothering him if you get swept away
he's he's it should bother him that you
are not together like that you are not
locked down right if look if he feels
like you are the best thing possible for
him don't get me wrong within reason
like you know you've known each other a
year maybe get engaged after a year or
two and you close the deal after another
year maybe or something like that but
the point is if he is lacks and he is
not he ain't treating it like it's Black
Friday uh you know when you see them
like rushing to grab the TVs and stuff
he is like yeah
she she is um always going to be there
I'm not worried about that and then I
can chance my options as seeing what
else comes along and if he if he doesn't
feel desperate to sign on the dotted
line then in my opinion
he isn't exactly
it's not that he doesn't love that
person I'm not saying that but he
doesn't think that she is of the maximum
value that his potential is capable of
getting and only as time goes by will he
maybe accept that and go maybe this was
my best you know what I mean yeah and
women are very understanding a lot of
the time and you you see women and I'm
like you do realize like 25 to 30 is
them them golden years and you're just
sitting there hoping for a for a for an
official move from him or a ring or
whatever you know what I mean and a lot
of them too patient and I I don't see
any problem for women out there to go
yeah
if you want to keep me you better make
this official and do that do the do you
know what I mean because otherwise I'll
find someone who will and I think having
a little bit of that in a relationship
is healthy because air from the man as
well like if if you have needs that
aren't being met say like I'll find
someone who will and I've said this
before in in arguments to be honest with
you and at the time it feels like you're
dropping a bit of a you know bomb like
oh God what's she gonna say here but in
reality I think it's good for you guys
to know hey I'm valuable
both of you have to feel valued and that
you both think you don't think I can't
get someone else to treat me well
because I can and I think that that's
healthy to feel that way nobody should
be in in a relationship feeling like
you could never do as good as me or any
you know like it's not a nice thing
that in my opinion you have to respect
each other and treat each other like
you're both a commodity you're both hot
property right well that's a tall
Telltale sign in a relationship if
you're feeling that way if you're
feeling like she'll never find anyone as
good as me or you know like that that's
not that's probably not the person that
you're gonna be with right like you
should be feeling lucky if you don't
feel both of you should feel lucky to
have each other like oh my God like I
want to be my best for this person not
like
and what do you have to say about the
men who um their excused for not getting
married is just a piece of paper I don't
want the government involved because
there's different thoughts about this
but I just want your I I think look I'm
very traditional I'm old school and I do
still believe in marriage and things
like that
I I know not a lot like some people
don't right and I think for men because
there's a power shift when you get
married for a lot of relationships the
woman then feels like got him
um and all of a sudden you know there's
a bit of more attitude and you know what
I mean and things I've seen it so this
isn't you know I'm I've seen this happen
where women know all of a sudden I get
half your [__] if this goes wrong at
least and then and then a monthly
payment as well which would be lovely
um so I understand why some men want to
avoid that right
and then some women do they don't take
value but I think there's something
sacred about marriage where it's like
this is a level above a relationship and
that's where the modern day I think have
gone wrong because they think they've
started changing the vows and stuff like
that because it's now just like
um I promise to love you until things go
wrong and then I'm off you know whereas
what marriage is for better for worse
richer for whatever happens we are going
to give each other that security that we
will always be there for each other and
that in the modern society which is just
easy come easy go it doesn't compute
that's why they're writing their own
vows and crazy [__] like that but in
regards to what you were saying earlier
as well about men and women who don't
feel like they need to make the effort
for each other as well we see that all
the time with men who let themselves go
or or women who who stop wanting to
appear in a more sexual way for their
men you know to keep the spike spice
there and stuff like that there's a lot
of that that goes on and I think that
that's one of the hardest things for men
is women don't necessarily understand
that like it is a challenge for men to
forego sleeping with other women because
we are pre-programmed to do that like
that is part of our genetic makeup we
see a woman walk past an attractive
woman and you're like okay I noticed
that it's the signals there in your
brain up and if you so that's always
happening but we are going against what
our biology is telling us as a way of
going I love you more than that you know
and as simple as that sounds I don't
think women understand that it's hard
for us hormonally because our
testosterones pump in we are being told
you know
um and just like women when women of
their hormonal time of the month we kind
of have to understand that but I don't
think women understand our hormones are
telling us
have sex as much as you can do you know
what I mean
right and I think you know
it's very unfair when we get into
marriages and then we just assume that
that person should love us forever
through all of our changes without any
effort on our part to continue trying to
be attractive to our partner because we
just say well they love me they should
love me no matter what which is like in
a sense very true like you don't want
your partner to be judgmental of you and
keep you on a strict diet and control
everything that you're wearing and
looking like but why are you just giving
up on yourself and why are you then
denying your partner any sexual you know
intercourse any intimacy you know I see
couples who they they don't get kisses
they don't hold hands they're in
separate bedrooms and it's you know and
then the man cheats and the everybody's
like a man Basher it's like okay but he
hasn't you know he's had been forced
into celibacy for five years so like
what can you do at that point like we're
all humans we're all driven to have this
connection so when it's denied or the
libido's not matching up or we just have
a high libido until we get the ring it's
like so unfair it's like false you know
outside of like having cancers or
something that like prevents you right
it's like of course yeah you know when
we give up on ourselves and we just
expect our partner to be okay with it
it's not fair either yeah just because
it says for better for worse doesn't
mean you can just choose the word does
it mean purposefully be worse just chill
you know like
but that does happen like people just
stop trying and I think that a marriage
um should be viewed upon as something
that requires consistent work yeah and
if that breaks down on one side it will
very quickly break down on all sides
like because let's say the woman's
talking to the man like [__] the man
then doesn't want to have sex with her
anymore the woman then will I don't know
Comfort eat then the man will not find
her a truck therefore and he'll go and
find a woman who's you know the the
smaller woman that you know he finds
more attractive or whatever so like it
is very easy for this to just
disintegrate and that's why you have to
choose carefully and that's what I was
referring to when I when you were
talking earlier about those men who
probably settled down when they were
younger and then changed into a
different person and it really is a
tricky one to know when to settle down
because like men are at their peak of
their powers in their 30s arguably
financially but women in their 20s seem
to be
um at the peak of male interest
and yet maturity Wise It's all [__]
all over the place it's like how do we
find the right match it's really
difficult right no I I would totally
agree and I think that both people in
their 30s kind of wake up yeah to I
don't really care about you know these
insecurities anymore I'm going to be
very straightforward about what I want
I'm going to set boundaries I understand
myself and then so we have this mix of
people who are like met older men or
going after young 20s and young 20s are
super impressionable and yes they're
full of life and they're very fertile or
whatever it is but they don't know
themselves yet and they don't have the
ability to connect so I actually think
that like men you know and I might get a
lot of pay for this no but like the
older you are going after young girls is
I think very inappropriate and very
wrong because your brain's not totally
developed and like you can say you're as
mature as you want I thought I was super
mature at 21 22 or whatever and now I
look back almost 30 and I'm like
I feel like I was you know not taken
advantage of because I had some sense of
boundaries but like if I would have
known I know now I wouldn't have gone
out with like a 35 year old when I was
20 years old because that's like such a
huge age Gap and like what did we have
in common nothing you know so it's kind
of like I can't imagine dating someone
who was like 50 at that time and I would
have been cool with it but like because
I didn't know any better it's like a
child I I think finding someone who is
on your level maturity is is massively
advantageous in a relationship and I
think a lot of the reason that men are
going for women if they're like 40 years
old or whatever and going for those
younger women is is because it's like
they're easier to get on board with what
they want right and because they don't
want to change and yeah and and because
men I guess find
women who have let's say played the
career role and are empowered uh
probably more difficult to impose their
will on in regards to what they are
wanting from relationship whereas if you
get a younger impressionable woman
you're gonna find it easier to go look
uh here she's easier to impress because
she hasn't experienced a lot of these
things like you're taking up places
doing things you got money so she's more
wet behind the ears and wow and then
she's then more happy to please you and
do the thing because you're telling her
well this is what this is what this is
what I do you know what I mean whereas I
don't know 30 year old woman has got her
own ideas and then how does that work
and these are rich men who just can't be
bothered with that a lot of the time so
I think that that's I completely agree
with you the ideal scenario is to be
much more in a Level Playing Field but
people want everything their own way
people want everything their own way but
that's not also not how relationships
work so when you're getting into a
scenario like you said those
relationships usually never last they
kind of cycle in and out right Leonardo
DiCaprio classic example yep you know
every time 25 hits
they're out right because they're mature
other and realize this isn't all that's
cracked up as well I don't know yeah we
got to get them on the podcast yeah I'd
love that yeah I I did wonder about that
well you know like as in for these men
out there who are talking about dating
down so much in age like what happens
when she changes and she finds herself
are you 50 years old now when on your
own that's a problem bro like he finds
another 18 year old damn yeah you know
that's the thing because when you're
young and you're 20 or whatever you're
like you said you see it as like oh my
God this is so cool that someone so much
older like is attracted to me and they
have the money and they have all this
experience and things that I don't know
about the world so you know you feel
kind of lucky to be in that relationship
and then you get older and you're like
I don't think uh this was already
thought it was anymore I have my own
ideas and he isn't like that or I start
to see him for who he really is because
now I'm developing an opinion on what I
like and what I dislike in a
relationship do men ever come to you
with like sexual problems not as like
their main point but it's always you
know like a side in the background it's
a thing that is there because of all of
the other problems that are happening
yeah I've seen you did a really funny
skit where basically you said like what
men are really thinking of before
they're about to have sex oh yeah and
all of their insecurities that are going
through their head of like I don't know
if she's ready for this I don't know if
I'm like uh gonna perform I can't really
talk to her and I thought that was a
really good point because men we want to
perform we want to be the guy you know
we want to make everything seem amazing
but ultimately that's not always going
to happen and men having a conversation
with a woman prior to having sex and
being like you know I'm a bit nervous
yes so let's just you know what do you
like you know all of these sort of
little conversations that you can have
to to sort of open up of each other and
be like you know we're about getting
naked where you know this is all right
we can talk about you know our
insecurities or here's something I like
or here's what I don't like or whatever
but man it does feel like men are still
in that habit of just trying to take
control and be the stallion I guess
right there's nothing wrong with like
trying to take control and be the
stallion but exactly like you said when
there's no room for communication and
men and women are both equally bad at
this in the bedroom because women are
shamed for having sex and men are shamed
for like not knowing how to be good in
bed even though nobody ever teaches them
about it and so like they're ashamed
like it you know and like nobody knows
what they're doing kind of because
they're not telling each other right
like women old fake an orgasm he'll come
early and just like you know make up
some excuse how he's got to go home and
then you know like both people are so
unsatisfied so you have to make space
for like hey I'm nervous like I'm really
attracted to you I might come fast like
what do you like to be done to you to
make you satisfied if this is going to
happen right like it's like oh holy [__]
no one's ever asked me before and like
let's explore this world together and
that's exactly the beauty that we were
talking about before with having you
know like
partners that you stick with that you
can build those because you're not going
to have that conversation with a
one-night stand
yeah exactly you're not gonna you're
just gonna get your whatever and go and
it just leaves you like so empty because
you're not understanding like the depth
of a person or the depth that your
pleasure could go to because when you
actually get vulnerable with someone you
have different pleasure points you
understand your own body in a different
way when that person touches it it is
okay if I meant to ask those questions
because women are so different from
woman to woman I think men are a lot
more easier to figure out right
anatomically yeah yeah and and women are
they vary in so many different ways from
in terms of what gives them uh pleasure
but also how they want you to behave
what is their ideal scenario because you
know personally as a man uh I feel like
women have a sort of stereotype of the
way I look and therefore the way I
should behave but I may not conform to
that or I may not be in that mood or
whatever you know what I mean but but
generally speaking the more I have asked
those questions with women the better
it's been and it's just about being like
not being scared to seem silly or ask a
stupid question or do you know what I
mean and and I think that is the bad
that is the hard bit of of having a lack
of uh maybe self-confidence in that I'm
talking specifically about when your
first like learning about women and
starting to sleep with women for a young
allad it's it is daunting because you
don't want to see him like you know I'm
new at this but you are new with this
you are you know what I mean so sad say
look I is this all right and if she's
figuring out with you then that's even
better because then neither of you
should feel pressured
um right and you asking relieves the
pressure of either person having to tell
the other one that they're doing
something wrong so like just remember
that like if you don't want to be told
that you're doing something wrong and
feel embarrassed from that you just ask
just ask first because it relieves the
pressure like oh we can both say what we
want and need here and we don't have to
feel embarrassed about it uh there's a
wave of men out there who have started
to avoid women it's this growing
movement on the internet have you heard
about this sort of in cell culture and
all of that and toxic masculinity is
being labeled at them as well or
whatever what is your take on that sort
of issue yeah I feel like a lot of men
are just kind of like stay single Kings
I find so much peace by myself because
I've had bad experiences with women
being toxic you know maybe
they think only using them for money or
whatever like you know they're not
getting what they want so they're just
kind of like checking out all together
um and I think in a way that's kind of
like taking the easy way out because
you're also just not addressing your own
issues or pain or anything at that point
like it's totally okay to be single and
to want to be single but to blame an
entire gender for the reason why you're
single says that you're not doing it in
a chosen healthy way oh it's I think
it's incredibly childish I think it's
embarrassing actually it's like I'm not
gonna go and touch any woman ever again
because they're all nasty at me like it
it's like come on man like what you've
got one life yeah like work on yourself
understand them better like and a lot of
it is just I guess they're very socially
awkward people who don't feel
comfortable with admitting some of their
own flaws and understanding themselves
better and it's it's it's such a weird
movement that I never thought we'd get
to to the point where men were like
opting out like that in their thousands
like it's it's a serious movement I
didn't realize how and what about toxic
masculinity generally do you believe in
that do you think that that's
because that's a thing that gets bonded
about in the media constantly I think
it's one of those things that once again
just gets like blown out of proportion
because what my initial understanding of
toxic masculinity was was the
unrealistic societal expectations put on
men
that were toxic to masculinity toxic to
masculinity because masculinity itself
is is not toxic right femininity itself
is not toxic but there's all these like
societal roles that are put put on us
that are just like that's the toxic
thing but it's just like now it's like
you're you're in toxic masculinity like
you're not listening to me and I think
that that's just like manipulating the
term or you know trying to get your your
way of it because like you said there's
nothing wrong with a man being a man
with a man be like experiencing his
anger or aggression or his ability to
fight because fight or flight isn't
necessary for all of us like if a
woman's child isn't dead or she she
definitely going to be in fight mode you
know like she's not she's going to be in
fighter she's going to run away she's
going to do what she can and like you
don't want to eliminate that and for men
it's usually fight right so you don't
want to eliminate that in a man because
like when you said when we need it we
need it I didn't even know that that was
the original sort of meaning I mean
that's what I had a thought of it but it
makes sense so that the whole man up
thing right that we used to be told
that's toxic masculinity and you know
that that that that that toxic side of
what masculinity was and the
expectations on men that just man up
that's the bad thing but in instead it's
now being used as like
if you're a manly man and I've
definitely experienced this online you
get
sort of pigeonholed in this you are this
you are this thing and it's like a
discriminatory thing really what do you
think of the red pill movement overall I
mean to be fair I have not like studied
them in depth because it's a very it's a
it to me it's like very toxic like I
don't I don't generally tend to like put
all of my energy and effort into people
who blame other people or things for why
they're the way they are because I just
feel like it's a victim mentality and
all does this serve to make you feel bad
about yourself right because I'm a woman
and with the red pill movement a lot of
it is like women aren't good wives women
become less valuable as they age and so
for me to do men's work
and then for men to comment on my posts
that like oh yeah women are so much less
valuable as they you know hit 30 and
whatever it's it's kind of like so it's
like what am I doing this for then do
you want me to vanish do you want to
have no Advocates do you you know like
you can't just [__] on the people who
are trying to help you and like it does
it just doesn't work that way you can't
get a good wife by [__] on all women
and how they're not good wives you can't
yeah you have to be an advocate for who
you want to be with right like I can't
just say all men suck and then I want to
be like Oh I'm just looking for a
husband who's gonna take care of me but
like I hate men it doesn't make any
sense I have to be like I love men I
want to help you and I'm going to align
with someone who has the same goals and
values and beliefs as me there's shitty
men out there but I'm not I'm not
looking at them I'm looking at the men
who want to help who want to change
themselves want to do things like this
so if you're a man who's struggling I
know the red pill movement might be very
attractive because you feel understood
and you feel valued and feel respected
but I want you to respect and value
yourself to a point where you don't need
to hate on other people in order to get
there I love that yeah I think you're
completely right
uh no you're so right because I feel
like feminism has become a similar thing
for women who feel hurt and
misunderstood by men and these two
Avenues can be very attractive when you
feel like a victim and you feel you've
been hurt you there was one or two or
three or four people who didn't
understand you didn't respect you
treated you bad and then you've got this
group of people who are hating the other
side going we've got all the answers
come over here and it's rubbish like and
there isn't anything that makes people
happier than a loving relationship not
money not nothing and you're not going
to achieve that by hating the opposite
gender as much as I'm I can be critical
of women or I can say look modern women
or this and this is a difficult thing
about them equally they're my motivation
in life not it why am I trying to be
successful I want to you know be able to
provide for a woman make her happy have
her build a life with her like I mean I
remember being 19 and my dad saying to
me well what's your motivation I was
like women you know what I mean now and
I think that's why men get so I don't
know drawn into the red pill movement is
because you know there are some common
sense things in both feminism and red
pill
but it's surrounded in anger and hurt
and I think that's what the a lot of
them find themselves gravitating towards
that fall
um so that they can stand over there and
point the finger and like I say they're
the bad guys I'm great nothing wrong
with me yeah right and then as they
um continue down that spiral it becomes
like you said they just opt out of
relationships all together and are they
actually happier I don't think so if
you're being a keyboard Warrior like
yeah a single Kings like you're just
repeating your pain over and over and
over again like she hurt me like you've
literally just made that person like the
master of you you've become a slave to
someone of your past they have literally
whipped you into single Hood where you
are now crying on the internet to
everybody that we need to also go to
Thailand and you know what like and I'm
so sorry because I just called up so
many people but like there's a thing
called passport Bros and it really
frustrates me it really frustrates
there's no good women in America but
like I've now hit 25 countries that I've
lived in I guess say for a month each at
least and everybody says this in every
country there's no good men here there's
no good women here I need to go
somewhere else I'm like you're telling
me and in every country I go to there's
no good men or women here and that you
have to go somewhere else it's like it
doesn't make sense you have to be where
you're at and understand who you are and
where you're at and then things will
change for you it's so ironic that these
you know quote unquote masculine men
think that they're so manly and yet a
woman broke your heart and now you're
crying about it in the comments of
YouTube from for years on end bro you're
the most feminine thing I ever did see
in my life man get back out there and
wear your heart on your sleeve like a
man and brave it stop hating you know
all women just because one of them hurt
you truthfully and I agree with you
about this idea of I'm just gonna go to
another country and find a bride who
will do everything I want because she is
being paid to that is not a solution man
like I understand you know it feels like
an extreme solution to a problem where
you're having a woman who is maybe a
nightmare right and you know let's say
you've got a UK woman who's you know
completely a bad match for you and you
think I'm just gonna go and find someone
who says yes to everything that's not a
solution because then you're not going
to feel like anything you're doing with
her is genuine like there's real love
there yeah and then it's empty so
um I mean what I did to be honest with
you when I've made my change in life and
decided to treat women differently and
and think differently is I played the
the sort of the numbers game a bit more
where
I went on the internet dating and I
wrote a nice profile
um I'll tell you what my my on my hinge
profile was uh dating me okay we gotta
make sure we know this I went I went on
hitch it was dating me is like uh
because they have like all your little
prompts right so I was dating me as like
Christmas there's a big bearded guy
giving you gifts and you eat a lot
that was a good line right that's funny
yeah and and you know I and I just
started like talking to women who I
thought were attractive and trying to
work out okay are we compatible because
that's something I'd never done before
and it's so basic because of course you
should be looking for someone who's
compatible but men we're looking for the
hot you know what I mean the hottest
girl we can find a lot of the time
that's your level of compatibility yeah
I'm like yeah yeah do I want to go there
okay
um and then I would have a phone call
because I wouldn't want to go on a date
and make all that effort without knowing
is there any even phone chemistry there
because if there's not phone chemistry
and it's awkward and we don't click and
we're not having you know laughing and
learning about each other and getting
along then we've got no hope there's no
hope so that was and I did that quite a
lot and I would do like and then if I
had a date and I was like I wouldn't do
a second date there's no way I'm doing a
second date if I'm yeah because I'm
thinking I'm in my 30s now life is you
know ticking along and I want to meet
someone here so I gave my I viewed
dating almost like a job not in a not in
a not in a difficult hard work kind of
way but more like I set myself
limitations and boundaries to go these
are the standards the criteria that I'm
trying to hit because otherwise I'm just
going to waste my time and I think that
that is one of the things that people
are doing more than ever is wasting time
going out with people who are just
clearly not right for them like I said
people who can't even speak their own
mind in front of their Partners after
five ten years of knowing them and I
didn't want to feel that way and that
paid off for me that attitude of I'm
just going to keep talking to people and
eventually I will talk to someone who
aligns with me and then there's
attraction yeah I think that's a good
way of going for people that's a perfect
I mean and actually because now then you
had some set standards and like you said
it's kind of like a job interview it's
like that's that's what dating is dating
isn't like hey I'm gonna see if I want
to be in a relationship with you it's
like hey I need to see like if we're
compatible and then we can see if we're
going to be in a relationship right like
and if you know people get stuck on like
the second person they kind of go on a
date with oh I kind of like them I kind
of want to see where it goes like no you
should know where you want to go and vet
for that first
so true and that's what I did and I was
asking them the questions like do you
want children you know are you um
why did you break up with your last
boyfriend did he break up with you why
what happened you know like I wasn't I'm
not scared of any of those answers I'm
not these the kind of guy who needs to
be convinced in the idea I'm the only
man you've ever known uh I think that's
a really childish way of viewing it as
well and that really helped me just
better understand people and realize
okay you would not be right for me for
this reason or like there was one girl
who was just like really lovely person
worked constantly and I was like that's
not going to work because I work a lot
so I need someone who can fit around my
life and that's not even in a
domineering Alpha attitude it was just
generally the the way it is and that
really helped me like
figure out how to meet people in a
better way and not waste my time that's
perfect I mean just as an example like I
had a client once who was
when he worked all the time and I said
who's your ideal person he's like yeah
maybe someone who has their own career
also you know maybe like a doctor or a
nurse and I said how is that going to
work out you think doctors aren't
working around the clock I'm like you're
a lawyer she's a doctor when you go see
each other we can have a relationship
it's hard enough to be with the doctor
in the first place I'm like you should
probably change your ideal you know I'm
not saying it can't work but I'm just
saying like that's probably where you're
missing the goal post yeah nurse is
actually apparently struggle for that
reason yeah because they are just so
they date each other within the work
unit and then think about it if you're
like let's say if you're a nurse or a
doctor especially nurses you're giving
so much care and energy to people all
day and then you've got to come home and
be caring and giving to your man it must
be hard
and for that reason it's a no from me
you know it's a no for me no I'm quite a
demanding guy I think I'm really trying
um traditional I think I'm a real like
old-fashioned kind of guy and I believe
I like gender roles I like doing the
manly stuff I like her doing the female
stuff and don't get me wrong that
doesn't mean I'm like unchallengeable or
anything like that I just mean
I just feel like it's it fits for me and
I think that that it's helped uh me in
relationships before because
I think it just eliminates a lot of the
confusion that men and women are finding
themselves in in terms of respect
because men really seem to be struggling
with that in terms of gaining that in
their lives from their partners and and
feeling respectful of themselves what do
you think men can do to help with that
going back to the main thing that we
said in the beginning is doing what you
say you're going to do okay immediately
helps raise your level of self-respect
because you're like
I know I'm gonna do what I say I'm gonna
do so it gives you this level of
self-confidence and after you do a
little thing after little thing then you
know you can do the big thing so you
start setting bigger goals right and
when you start setting bigger goals you
start achieving the bigger goals then
you have a sense of self-worth and
self-value and then you stop kind of
looking at women as on a pedestal
right men do that for sure yeah men do
that for sure when they feel insecure
about their worth and their value women
can sometimes a little bit
they play on that as well or if they
smell a bit of that they'll do a little
bit more of that to gain a bit of ground
like power in a relationship like I
don't know if you that's their role yeah
you know it's like listen like we don't
want to like
women's power is
the word because they don't have the
physical strength so we have to use our
minds and we have to use our seduction
to get what we want and if we want them
like right like this is just the way of
the divine feminine also you don't want
a woman to lose that actually you just
want to be a man who's competent enough
to play the game
for real yeah you you it's a it's a
healthy thing when when managed
accordingly right it's just like if
you're too weak to that or she's too
strong with that it can kind of become
unbalanced right someone once described
it as um the woman's the the woman is
the flame and we're the moth and like
almost attracted to it but not getting
too close to get burned
um and my dad actually once told me like
um relationships are just constantly
like an adjustment of power depending on
what is going on and balancing that and
I I do I do agree in terms of ending
relationships let's say you you know
you're you needed a divorce or something
like that and you feel like you're stuck
uh how do how do your clients
um exit those relationships in in the
healthiest of ways and and how hard is
it because obviously
divorces and separation they seem to
really hit men hard because when men
seem very loyal in their commitments to
women like and it can destroy men
the divorce situation
yeah and this is like the really
unfortunate thing like
you know I think that like you said
marriage is a very sacred thing but
unfortunately the government does tie
its hands into it and and for good
reason sometimes you know if the woman
is if it is traditional role she doesn't
have a career like she's gonna need that
support and if you're a man who's had
children with a woman who she has been
traditional you should want to support
her even if you separate because that
was the agreement right but every state
at least in the United States has
different laws for marriage and for what
happens after so I think you really need
to be prepared before you get married to
understand because everybody has a
prenup just depending on what state
you're in so write something so that
when you're both in love
you can agree on most people don't do
that they're like we're never going to
get divorced fair enough but like now
you haven't prepared for it so now you
have to be subject to the laws of the
state so it's different for my clients
because they're all in different states
depending on the laws of the state and
depending on the spouse if the spouse
that they've married is is somewhat you
know committed to you know the promises
that they kept in marriage even in
separation it's usually equal but I
usually tell the men no matter what go
in with a calm state of being
because you can kind of shift the
dynamic of the relationship by not
making her the enemy and then stick with
your boundaries for like because I see a
lot of men kind of give more than they
should of course because they don't want
to create any problems but then all it
does is give permission for her to ask
for more and you just gotta put up a
boundary yourself because sometimes the
state's not even asking for it the
lawyers don't even asking for you just
like okay take this take this this is
all that I want the guilt from men are
leaving because you feel bad about it
and it's funny I watch this viral clip
of um what would you say to your ex
right now and it was men against women
and women being like I tell them to eat
[__] and die and then men going I just
hope she's having a happy life like and
it was like consistent like yeah like
con and women I think find it easier to
sort of
turn the guy into a villain in their
head emotionally and I'm not making them
a dig at them it's it's often because
it's so painful that it's easier to be
like you're my enemy just to get over
this period whereas men can often let go
um a bit more calm well they're very
logical well because they blame
themselves right they make themselves
the enemy absolutely and it's easy to do
that when the woman's telling you you're
a piece of [__]
um it's like maybe uh
but in terms of the mental health side
of it obviously it's it's a hell of a
rebuild to go through after men
obviously find themselves
um starting a new life and
alone yeah well and also because we said
there's no sympathy for men anytime you
get to ask a friend who's getting
divorced and you say what happened and
they're always going to lean towards it
was the man's fault like your your
subconscious assumption is that he did
something wrong well that's I mean when
80 of divorces are initiated by women
that's ironic it's like I'm leaving and
it's your fault I'm doing the action of
leaving but it's your fault but
sometimes men will do this too they will
do things so that she will pull the
trigger so that he doesn't have to feel
good I completely agree
so we're blaming women over here like
yeah she had the audacity leave me yeah
because you were doing all these things
on purpose yeah and you didn't want to
be blamed no you are so so right in that
and I think um and I've been in
relationships before where not not in
this sort of level not not in a divorce
setting but but you know in a way where
I realize
where we're having an argument where
we're trying to manipulate the argument
to make uh we're trying to who can get
the victim status
you know like you're the perpetrator
because of this this and this and then
oh no I'm the victim because and it's
like
that that was a a point in my life where
I realized God this is so immature who
cares man you know what I mean like what
are we [__] competing over here the
victim state is when this is [__] yeah
this is [__] why are we still doing this
and um I think it's a real habit that
people get into because it's a lot
easier to claim victim than it is to
take accountability for your percentage
obviously not 100 but whatever you did
wrong
um and that's often where you just know
you're not even in a relationship with
someone who's mature enough to work with
you to mend those scars and heal each
other I like what we were saying earlier
I think that is actually like
the The Telltale of a great relationship
is people who can apologize well to each
other and make each other feel better
afterwards when you're in a healthy
relationship it no longer feels good to
win alone like winning the argument and
feeling like your partner lost it
doesn't feel good to you nope you know
like you want to get to a point where
you're like okay how can we find a
win-win right because yeah if you're in
a healthy relationship like because
sometimes too if you know you're in an
immature relationship if you're just
trying to explain how you feel and get
the point across and then they're doing
that thing to you and then it gets
exhausted like man I didn't want to
fight with you I just wanted you to
understand my perspective so that we can
move forward and now I feel bad that I
brought something up and you're thinking
that I made you the enemy and it's just
so crazy like just get to a point where
you can say how can we make this a
win-win with every argument how can how
can I walk away from this making them
feel better than when we started I think
that's absolutely fantastic advice
because if you don't get to a point
where you can do that where you feel
like okay yeah we went through a bit
ever an argument there but you know what
we both understand each other better now
and I'm really glad we had this out
actually that's a healthy relationship
but what you were describing before in
that the the confusion the spaghetti of
it all where you know you're trying to
get a point across and it's changing of
subjects misdirection and all that
that's where I feel at my most helpless
where I'm just like I'm just giving up
because I actually don't have the faith
in you to even understand where I'm
coming from I feel like you don't care
yeah because you're too busy trying to
win not here what I'm saying
um and that's really
where the breakdown comes from either
side men or women I guess and men have
less capacity to try because they don't
Nest they don't become vulnerable
they don't have the ability to become
vulnerable so often so when they do and
they get rejected or that cycle happens
to them they shut down immediately right
so it's kind of like if you're in a
relationship with a man you have to like
take that into stock that like oh my God
I really need to like nurture this
moment because you know it's so much
harder for men to open up do you think
that's down to like the inner child sort
of thing like what happens to us when
we're younger sometimes
yeah I mean specifically for men because
they're taught to just man up so little
boys are treated differently than little
girls you know growing up and when they
skin their knee it's kind of like rub
some dirt on it you know and the girl's
crying it's like Oh Come here sweet baby
angel you know and like so men see that
you see that as a little boy and you're
like oh well my Pain's not necessarily
as important as her pain so true you
know and that's that's how you approach
relationships my Pain's not as important
as her pain I'll just keep it inside
then it kills you
because that pain is real
um doesn't just go away it builds up you
actually once said that men and women
view relationships differently and you
compare to Jenga and I really like this
comparison in that men see the entirety
of the structure whereas women see the
tiny little details of it all can you
elaborate on that yeah so I'm glad that
you liked that because I worked really
hard on that process the game Jenga is
like the game is like how many small
pieces can I take out before the tower
Falls
and how men see things is like they see
things as the big picture so like as
long as the relationship is still
together they say oh the tower is still
together this is okay but the women are
like he didn't take the trash out he
didn't say yes to his brother's wedding
and now I've got to do all this stuff
and I've got to do all the chores and so
like every time something happens in the
relationship like a little piece is
missing and that's what she sees because
she sees the the fact that the little
things build up the structure so then
one day when one piece too many comes
out he's like
the structure has gone over that one
thing and she's like didn't you see all
of the holes in the tower the Jenga
Tower doesn't fall because one piece is
missing it falls because too many pieces
are missing for this to be stable
anymore that is actually genius because
that is thank you no that it really is
because that that's the best analogy
I've heard in terms of how men and women
view relationships differently it's so
true yeah because we are just trying to
see the bigger picture we are just
trying to get through life and make sure
that like Bill's appeared in the idea
and oh well I took when when women say I
guess from memory classic example is
women have maybe accused me of oh well
you didn't do this this and this and I
go yeah well I took you out on Saturday
and yeah it's like well that doesn't
for all of the little things that you
didn't you know make happen or whatever
so I wonder if you could just get like
and I've thought about this too if you
just get a Jenga game so both of you can
see it and just keep it on the counter
and every time like oh the woman gets
upset or feels like a piece is missing
she takes one out and puts it on a piece
of paper and like no tastes it so he
sees okay there's a piece missing and
this is what is upset by her and he can
do the same thing and then when
something awesome happens you put a
piece back in right like I don't know
it's just like a tangible way to see the
problem yeah on relationships it amazes
me that when you think about it the this
is the sort of thing that teenagers
should be getting taught in school yeah
how to communicate in a relationship how
to have a successful uh understanding
relationship with a man or a woman
depending on what you're into and
instead we're learning like
you know history or whatever yeah yeah
algebra and it's this is It's essential
for a happy life well how could it be
taught in schools if nobody knew nobody
was following this the rules for a
healthy happy relationship before would
just shut up and live life
and I think that there are very few
happy like the Happy couples that you
see like on Instagram they're super old
like they're like really Diamonds in the
Rough I think and they're so magical and
they're so special and that's that's
like what we all want but I think it is
actually very rare but it starts
from you know healthy families right
like you'll see a lot of those patterns
of you know families that kind of stay
together through the generations they
have the the internal Compass is this
thing right when you Branch out to like
the bigger cities it's kind of like the
internal compasses we don't have to stay
together I'm a single parent like this
is just the way things are and it makes
it so much easier to go to that to make
that the First Choice yeah like I don't
even think people are finding it that
important to be staying together after
having children yeah but it's so crazy
you know as I've done this work like I
used to not want to get married and not
have kids I was like [__] them kids like
I don't I don't need that I'm gonna be a
billy like I'm gonna do my thing and now
that I'm
I do want more of a traditional family
life when you say it catches up with you
what does that mean does that mean you
maybe one day woke up and felt more like
because you know how someone's people
say biological clock and all of that do
you feel like that was part of it or did
you just come to that realization on
your own
who I thought
I want to have kids with this person wow
which I never thought that would ever
happen to me because I never thought
that for anybody else
um and terrify actually getting pregnant
was like my worst fear in the world
it terrified me
and then you went from that of wanting
to be pregnant yeah to being like I
could I think I could see myself having
kids with you and then I started
thinking about that and then I started
wanting that right and that
relationships didn't work out but
obviously I don't have kids that I'm not
married but then it it just changed my
whole world view because then I started
to look at things so much different of
like why do I want
so much money why why do I want to be
successful because like I've been doing
this for like so many years and
traveling to different countries and
stuff and it's like I hear the same
complaint even from my clients and like
you hear the same complaint from people
who are very old like doing things by
yourself loses its Allure
it loses its Sparkle it's not fun
and like you would trade it when you're
80 years old all of the work that you
did to have a life with someone special
yeah I'm I'm a big believer that money
is only as good as the quality of the
people that you've got to spend it on
right I think for women men it's
different because men are kind of taught
from an early age okay you should have a
career because you're gonna need to
support a family whereas women are being
told now correct me if I'm wrong but it
feels like women are being told you need
to have your Independence
um in case a man doesn't support you or
in case he leaves you or whatever but
happiness isn't really thought about
it's security and stability and I'd get
me wrong I think they're essential but
for women now I have met a lot of women
you know moving to London where I felt
like
you guys are sort of
hitting 30 and kind of coming to that
realization of like I'm I'm just making
my boss more money really I'm not really
you know like
making myself happy or building anything
that I feel like in the long like I
watch this Kevin Samuels keys I you know
um and don't get me wrong
Kevin Samuels if people have never heard
of him he's like a 50 year old image
consultant who would tell women a lot of
the time why they don't have a partner
and yeah he was a bit brutal but there'd
be truth in in the things that he was
saying in regards to the kind of men
they want and what those men are then
looking for right and it would blow
their minds and these are women who
would spend
20 plus years from being 20 years old to
you know their late 30s 40s still
without a family without children and
they'd just been doing it their way
their way their way and when they got
into relationships because they were in
the masculine energy of I'm a go-getter
I'm a determined career woman it's not
gelling with a man and men are just like
you know I'm not really into that and
leaving and they they sort of all seem
to regret it and I think it's
maybe women now need to Veer a little
bit back from okay yes be independent
yes have a career but also take time for
your love life as well because actually
in the long term that is actually what
makes women happier than Independence
and career and all of that no I totally
agree I actually have like a conspiracy
theory that I mean mean partially a
conspiracy theory like the birth control
companies because I think big Pharma
runs so much at least in the United
States like getting girls on birth
control at a young age messes with their
hormones and after being on it for so
many years it makes you like infertile
so then they make money from having to
do in vitro fertilization and things
like that but it also like it delays
your hormonal process right like so
you're not getting the biological clock
you're not falling into because you
don't have as much estrogen right so of
course the women are all becoming more
masculine and then their time clock is
being delayed and then so what happens
if women are starting to freeze their
eggs and you know like so they can do
more career and then by the time they
get there and then like you said they're
kind of like too old to partner with
someone and then they might have a child
by themselves you know it's like also
one of the main one of the main factors
You could argue if you were believing in
that that this is all one big conspiracy
is well part of the thing is that
statistically
fertility is plummeting right right so
that's all true not even offered a
debate but the reason why they wanted to
you know allegedly the government would
want to attack the family unit is
because what's the good in just having
the dad pay taxes let's have the dad and
the man pay taxes let's get them both
out there working let's masculinize the
the females and make them think that
this is go get them Single Ladies you
know what I mean and
um and my only experience on this was uh
I was with a woman who was like really
lovely person
I'll never forget this she went on the
birth control pill it went crazy Balkan
personality change was insane it was
like a different human I'm I'm talking
from an angel to
a very difficult human to be around like
and I couldn't I was like like I'm on
antidepressants right like I need to I'm
on there search early and I don't know
if you've ever heard of Sertraline
um
and certainly in you know is a strong
drug
and yet
my you know the impact on me is
literally it just curbs my temperament
keeps me emotionally more stable it
doesn't have that much of an impact on
me by comparison this was a 180 degree
change in a person that I've never and
it made me realize like because I've
dated quite a few women who've been on
antidepressants and it's like well
you're also on birth control is the
antidepressant just balancing out what
the [__] birth control is doing to
you as well and when when these women as
I've said I've been so in their
masculine energy it's like well if the
if the government are telling you all go
out be single ladies be independent
you're getting pumped full of hormones
that are making you more masculine you
then fertility is plummeting it's like
it's all it's like a whole organized
orchestrated approach to change men and
women
um as we once knew them and then we're
also being bombarded with you know other
imagery out there of what men should be
or shouldn't be which is feminizing men
right and all the estrogen in the in the
food yeah that's what they say it's like
it's really really crazy and and there
was no man boobs in the 1930s what
should we do men will go to the doctor
say hey your testosterone so why don't
you get a testosterone shot yep we're
like losing our minds about like going
back to like just being logical and
instead of putting more and more stuff
in our bodies to try to control these
things that we feel like are out of
control
we need to just let our bodies regulate
themselves like your your program to
continue on so if something is imperfect
in your functioning your genetics will
figure that out you know there's nothing
wrong with getting help or you need it
but to think that every solution every
solution is in medicine and manipulating
our hormones is just crazy and that is
the attitude of
um more more like you know you need you
know Domino's like you need a sleeping
tablets
everything the food is like all of the
the meats are pumped full of stuff the
pesticides and it is overwhelming how
much we're being bombarded and I'm glad
you can see that as well it does make me
think like
are you yourself on birth control or
anything like that yeah well so here I
use I was on this um I had never heard
of I not that I'd never heard of it but
like I didn't know anything about birth
control until I was like 23. I actually
got my first birth control in London
okay it's free
um because my partner at the time said
oh we should get you on birth control
and I was like oh why and I didn't
understand the reason for why people
went on birth control like besides
preventing pregnancy but I thought
always you use a condom right anyway
that's a good point that didn't have any
hormones in it it moved and I had to go
on the pill for a short period of time
that's why I know what you're talking
about when I went on the pill for like a
month I felt like I was going crazy I
would cry at like the drop of a hat I
would get pissed off and I was like I
don't know what's wrong with it honestly
I didn't know what was wrong with me I
was going crazy
um and now I have a different IUD that's
also hormonal because in the United
States you have to pay for everything
right copper IUD no hormones twelve
hundred dollars last 10 years hormonal
IUD seventy dollars
last seven years why is the hormonal one
so much cheaper than the copper one
right
um so yeah that's definitely on my list
to get it taken out and I've wanted to
for a while but I can't just like take
it you know it's not an easy thing like
stopping the pill is it's like I have to
go in and do it and you know with
Healthcare in the US it's just difficult
to go places so it's like I know you
feel a little bit trapped you feel like
a little bit trapped also because it
there's so much pressure on women to be
the people to prevent it and obviously
you want to prevent it because you're
the one who has to carry the baby right
but it's like damn dude it's like
there's so limited options and it has
such a huge impact on on who you are and
it's like it's really kind of rough
yeah that that experience it blew my
mind I worry about actually like when I
get off of this
um who I might be because I feel like
normal right I don't feel like it has a
big impact like the pill did but it does
worry me because they say that like you
can get depression after and that like
because your body has to normalize out I
mean yeah I'm like will I connect with
men anymore when I can see it I don't
know like I really wonder this because
hormones impact was like Mega don't they
so like you are blissfully unaware of
what this is doing to you but you it
will be changing the way your thought
patterns are it just will won't it and
like with me with antidepressant summer
when I came off my antidepressants
uh I just thought you know what I don't
think I need them anymore and the the
crash was Monumental it was scary did
you go to cold turkey
uh I I sort of decreased by 50 and then
eventually did nothing and it wasn't
immediate it was because there's so many
side effects with with sertraline
regarding like uh you'll be like up five
ten times a night needing away uh and
it's like and the sexual side effects as
well like you're not quite the same it's
not like you can't you know get an
erection but you're just like you don't
feel like you're able to uh finish the
way you know it's like a bloody
nightmare basically and there's a lot of
other issues with sleep and
um just slight issues here and there and
I thought you know what let me just get
off and see how this goes and within two
months
I was suicidal you know like but so I'm
just wondering though because I also
have had a client who is weaned off and
arguably these are like the hardest
moments of his life you know just the
things that we were going through when
he was feeling better than ever because
he started to address these things that
were causing the depression and
sometimes I think we don't we we can't
solve what we don't see like sometimes
you don't see what's causing the
depression right or you don't feel like
you have the support or like the right
support hasn't come to you and also if
you've been on something for so long
that's like you're addicted to it like
eventually your body stops making
what is already being supplemented to it
right so there's just something in that
that's like you know I'm not saying like
get off of it or anything I'm just
saying like I don't think always these
companies have our best interests at
heart and there's some level of
addiction that we get caught up in
because some people are on
antidepressants they're still really
happy right like life doesn't
necessarily change it's just like so
then you're like well when is it going
to start working yeah right but you know
what I completely agree with you and I
think that they're over prescribed way
more than what they should be I mean the
amount of women I've met who are on them
and as I say I'm like you can't all need
like this is a lot of women who are on
them now like God only knows how many
yeah yeah
um but for me the reason why I fully
believed that they were the right course
of action was they say oh it should take
you two weeks to notice the difference
and within three days I was like oh I
feel a bit less like because I was
absolutely wanting to like end my life
when I started them I was like if that
had gone on a few more weeks that might
have been the end of me and I
immediately felt the difference and
again
um
I just think I have a deficiency in
serotonin in my body because or
something like that because did you know
it's actually been scientifically proven
that there's no such I've seen that
study yeah from the holistic
psychologist I don't know if you've all
heard no I heard that yeah and I I
couldn't believe it because again I'm
like well what is going on then because
well it might be supplying you
definitely with something that you don't
have yeah right like but who's to say
where that deficiency was truly caused
from at this point again my body has
been bombarded with all sorts from birth
and God knows what other impacts that
other people are going through out there
where we're now needing something like a
Sertraline to just feel normal right
because again I'm on I'm on this
antidepressant I don't feel great by the
way like I still feel depressed I still
feel we need to get you out of that yeah
well no reason you should feel depressed
well part of the problem I think don't
get me wrong like it is Megalo without
Sertraline because I'm literally
thinking
um on a daily basis like I just wish I
wasn't here I just wish I wasn't I was
you know what I mean all of that sort of
stuff it's the constant like the brain
telling itself like you know where a
Sertraline helps me
it sort of cushions that so it's like
it's kind of muffled it's like sometimes
it's there sometimes it's not there
sometimes I feel you know what today is
[__] great it's a bit more normal
um like what my life used to be like but
I've I have been through a lot of trauma
which is probably you know I've been
through a [__] ton actually
um and maybe that's part of the the
overall reason but equally without this
I don't know what I would do you know
what I mean right well and that's what I
think where it's really a powerful tool
but it's kind of like nobody nobody
teaches you how to use the tools so that
you're a skilled Craftsman as opposed to
they just give you the tool and say
Here's your tool and you kind of just
hold it for the rest of your life saying
at some point something will get fixed
right and so like you want to take it so
that you feel neutral right because
you're not getting anywhere when you
feel so low
um that's just going deeper and deeper
down the hole but then then they just
give it to you and they like throw you
to the Wilderness say you're okay now
and you're like but you saying I'm still
depressed or like you know it's neutral
like that's the best it's gonna get like
breaks my heart because like life is not
meant to be like that like I want to
help you you know what I mean like we
are not meant to just have it be in the
back of our head like nobody taught you
how to handle the trauma no no no I mean
they definitely didn't and it one of the
other problems is I probably should be
on a higher dosage if if you're going by
what the doctor says but I can't because
when I go on a higher dosage I end up
wanting to piss all through the night
and I can't even [__] live like you
know what I mean like I can't even wake
up in the morning like so I'm just like
so I can't even live you know I I want
to do this
I literally want to have an orgasm and
be able to [__] sleep so I they need
a certain amount just to stop myself
from killing everybody
um it's [__] crazy really when you
think about it but like how how many
other people out there are feeling like
me probably a lot
um and as you say it's like drugs for
this drugs are drugs but you know what I
mean and that's sort of and in terms of
understanding trauma and like the level
of trauma I've been through you know
it's uh
without going into in the full detail on
a podcast it's it's
crazy I don't even know how I'm here I
honestly have no idea how I'm how I'm
alive and and then to go through all of
that to then get on the internet and put
your videos out there and generally I'm
just trying to entertain people and have
a laugh and hopefully people like that
and sometimes I'll say things that I
know are a little bit annoying right
because you know you have a difference
of opinion on fighting on boxing on
football or whatever but the level of
vitriol and abuse you're then subjected
to so I was like man my own brain's
already telling me I'm a [__] and
criticizing myself constantly so then
you have the waves of abuse coming
through as well it's it's a bizarre life
that I'm living like I'm like [__] me
this is you know I never thought when I
was eight years old that this many
people I don't know would tell me I'm a
[__]
um so that's a weird one uh but yeah I
mean thank God the meds are there don't
get me wrong because honestly like I say
I really did need them but like you say
that's when when you want counseling or
whatever you get like a rationed amount
of sessions where they're just like yeah
we'll give you half an hour and you know
like and even the the counselors
themselves know the service is so
difficult for people to really benefit
from because they're overworked
underpaid understaffed ah it's a [__]
nightmare yeah and with all of the rules
around counseling
you're just there talking to yourself uh
right you know because they don't give
you reaction items that's the problem
that most men come to when they you they
see me they're like yeah it was really
nice to like get off my chest but then
I'm like what now like how do I fix this
how do I heal this and I'm like I I
understand because that's what I
experience too and I love my therapist
she's still my therapist but like you
have different people for different
things in your life and when you really
want to solve something you have to go
to someone who can help you fix it and
thank God for medication like you said
but that should be the starting point
and a stepping stone to the next part of
your life where you where you start to
understand what you've gone through and
what you've been through because as much
trauma as you've been through
that doesn't mean you're absolved of
hope that you can live a happy Amazing
Life yeah and I I spoke to a woman who
was a victim of an attack from a man and
it was horrendous and she said how much
therapy it helped her so I've I've seen
that it can do that you know
um but it's just you know well and
that's also because women really get a
lot out of talking yeah right like men
and women are different so men
experience therapy in such a different
way
yeah when I did do a little bit of
therapy I remember I would leave
and I'd feel like I'd dug everything up
and I'd be like and now it's just there
yeah just walking around with it after
refreshing it all and that that is quite
challenging and sometimes
um and I'm not pointing any fingers but
I do wonder and maybe this is a good
thing for you to say is some people seem
to talk to therapists who I know
and I'm like your therapist can't be
being honest with you like like you know
when like I I knew an [__] who was
basically just like
getting me to feel better about this
[__] Behavior instead of really
having someone tackle it with them and
do you ever think that therapists can
kind of just go feel better about what
you did yeah I mean because therapists
are not Gods they're just humans and
some people can abuse their positions
just like anybody else I think that
there are some incompetent therapists
who've gone through school and don't
actually know or don't actually care
about what they're doing they just want
to make money just like anybody else on
the thought though of like someone who's
an [__] and like they're getting
coddled or whatever sometimes like you
just need to help that person feel like
understood for their actions but I think
it's also important to tell people this
is inappropriate
I mean I don't know if what I do is the
best but I'm saying like this is how I
do it right because I don't want someone
to like if I need someone coaching me
I'm going there because I know
something's wrong that I'm doing so I
need you to tell me what's wrong because
I don't I can't see it so I need someone
to point out all this stuff steps and
tell me what do I do now because then I
can learn and then I can do it
differently
so that's how I coach my men and also
just another thought on when you went to
therapy and people are digging stuff up
you don't actually need to dig up your
trauma in order to heal from it and
actually that was an old way of doing
therapy where they would just have you
repeated again and again and again and
they thought that you were healed
because you would no longer be
emotionally reactive but actually you
were just dissociating from it so we
found that it's no longer effective
um
to have people continue repeating their
trauma unless you bring it up right
because it just serves to re-traumatize
you and you never get over it
um yeah
I'd have to like write lists out and
stuff like that but I think to be honest
I was I was younger at the time and I
think I was too immature at a really you
might not have been ready do the work as
they say and I know a lot of guys who do
this there's there's men out there who
they find a woman who is a bit of a
project who who needs help or saving and
they think that it's on them to be the
white knight in shining armor and I know
you've mentioned this before
um why do men do this and what kind of
things do they do in these relationships
there's so many different facets as to
why right but there's you know the
pressure of like the man has to be the
leader and he's the one who protects and
provides and women who are down
they need someone who can help them out
they need someone who can save them so
he will be attracted to her because he's
like oh I can help I can fulfill my role
as a man with her
and then where it gets into a really big
problem on so many levels is a he does
it at the disservice of himself because
usually someone who is down and out on
themselves they're not usually like in a
place to work on themselves and so he
foregoes his own needs his wants his
responsibilities in order to do what
makes her good and then if he builds her
up
she's now built up to the point where he
has
[Music]
um built her up out of his job right his
job was to be her Savior and now she no
longer needs savings so usually she'll
leave or they'll no longer get together
and then he's angry because he's like
this is all I did for you I was you know
and his subconscious thought he does not
do this on purpose but the subconscious
thing is I chose you because I thought
you would never be able to leave me
exactly I thought you would never
abandon me and now you're leaving me how
dare you I saved you I did all these
things for you I used to feel sorry for
you like that's a big one and a lot of
these guys they feel sorry for these
women and I watched this show where um
there was this woman who had her body
was basically ravaged after having
multiple children she needed a makeover
and this man had supported her they had
a sexless marriage and he was there for
us through thick and thin not thin but
you know and uh she got her surgery make
all that look Glam and then at the end I
knew this was coming the end of small
she then left him right afterwards and I
was like supported her through all of
that you know and
um you do see that when they feel like
okay now I've got my confidence I don't
need you anymore and you're almost like
because you lowered your standards to
get her and she's lowering her standards
by taking you on
so you've both had low standards when
you got in this and now both of you are
like once you get your confidence you
get out of that when both of you hit
your confidence you get out of that
because you have to be in a lower state
of self-confidence to say I'm going to
choose someone who I feel like is weaker
than me if you're seeing your partner is
like weaker than you or less than you
like that's a reflection on yourself of
like I don't deserve someone who's at my
level
so true I've had these conversations
with my guys before where I've been like
that's not your job bro your job is not
to therapize her to fix her your job is
to find someone who's on your level
you're not there to make exceptions for
her inadequacies as a person she's
supposed to improve your life she's just
being a burden to you you're what are
you getting from all of this [__] but he
doesn't see it like that because he
feels like a hero and he feels like she
loves him and maybe they do love each
other right like there's no we're not
disregarding that there's love there I
mean there's just not an equality there
it's it's a different kind of
relationship it's almost like
father-daughter relationship right like
dad's gonna take care of me Dad's Gonna
Save Me So I I love him and then it's
usually not sexual right it's it's
really like a father-daughter
relationship and he adores her like a
daughter he wants to take care of her
once particular but in your romantic
relationships you don't necessarily have
that desire you you want to protect and
provide but you don't want to like take
care of them like a child not resp not
in a responsibility and that's exactly
what I said to my mate once I was like
you're not her dad you know what what is
going on here I mean that sort of brings
us on to Daddy Issues generally because
men often do get robbed into a life with
women with those sort of Hang-Ups and
end up trying to be that role I know
I've definitely found myself all of a
sudden like how the [__] did this happen
because I looked like that you know I
mean like I I you know if it wasn't for
women with daddy issues I'd be a virgin
I always say that because I've just
attracted them my whole life pretty much
but how do men sort of avoid uh you know
in your opinion maybe becoming that that
character for a woman do you have to set
boundaries or yeah I mean you have to do
a whole slew of things because usually
if you get into relationships like that
it's because you haven't been shown what
a healthy relationship Dynamic looks
like and it's usually coming from like
we said uh men with single mothers they
they also have daddy issues no Daddy
right so true daddy's not there I had
that I I had this feeling you said if I
would be a virgin if I didn't have girls
with daddy issues because you're a man
with daddy issues I had that abandonment
feeling of you know what what was wrong
with me and all of that yeah and then so
you you go to a woman who is down and
out and you think if I can save her it
you know subconsciously it will heal
this pain that I feel inside and finally
I will be worthy enough for love that I
didn't get
I will have have earned it and it will
kind of like make up for the past of
like not feeling good enough but it
never does it never fills the wound okay
so I'm gonna turn uh turn on to you
before we end uh you said that you're
you're in the mop it now you're feeling
like you know what I want I want this
life this is what I want what kind of
man are you looking for because the men
out here are going to be looking at you
thinking she understands men is there a
thing in your head or you just sort of
open-minded no there is I mean
absolutely there's a definitely a
specific thing in my head I don't
necessarily want to ask for it because I
feel like the man who sees me
I I want the man who sees me to know
that like I'm the one right like and
I'll know that energy like he'll know
who he is right like the people who are
looking for my answer are the ones who
are usually you know oh you don't want
to people that come at you with that
energy on a on a I seen you said this
yeah so now let me pretend to be this
yeah that and also I think people just
need to be themselves right like so I
would say for anybody who's you know
looking for a specific type of woman
just be a specific type of man be who
you are whether you have divine feminine
or masculine as your dominant just be
fully in that and look for your match
right look for your match know what your
internal Compass is right like for sure
true and true I need a man who does what
he says he's going to do
like he cannot be without that he cannot
be a dishonest man amen to that sister
he has to be he has to be and you know I
think it's and this is like a personal
thing I don't want to make this into a
personal part of the podcast but it's
like I get bombarded with the women are
losing their value as they age and you
know men don't want women who are such
high Achievers and stuff but at this
point I'm like what else can I do right
because I'm getting older and I'm
naturally a high achiever like I want
big success so the pool of men that I'm
looking for I'm not looking for someone
less successful than me because if I
want traditional roles I have if I want
a provider he's gotta make more money
than me and now I'm getting higher and
higher up this you know bar like I can't
help that because what am I supposed to
do just stop and hope that someone no
that's not a solution it's like I have
to continue growing and looking up so I
need a man who is also continuously
growing and who's also a little bit
ahead of me you know I think
intellectually that is important as well
with someone who's such a smart woman
like yourself like just someone who can
hang with you in a conversation because
you could just run rings around a lot of
these guys I'm sure
um and also a man whose understanding of
what your work is I guess because right
because you know that's actually the the
problem that I have is like I don't want
to tell people what I do I don't want to
tell people what I do because they
either think that I'm like they're like
oh you're gonna psychoanalyze me and it
totally kills off any sexual intimacy
that you know it just kills it or
they're like oh I have some problems I
need and I'm like okay great I'm like a
kindergarten teacher or something you
know or like or people like fangirl you
which is like I love you my men yeah
have you had men who were conflating
your services as you know someone who
helps them with falling in love with you
sort of thing no because you have to pay
to speak to me like so people who are in
in the coaching with me they're full on
about it but definitely people in like
the DMS and they'll say you you know
weird things like you know and like I
get it though right because think about
it right even like for example when I
first seen your videos you come across
as someone who's so in tune with men and
you're so understanding and it is not I
mean we've seen uh Tony Soprano on The
Sopranos falling in love with his uh
therapist because men just feel
understood and they're like oh wow she
gets me you know all right but I'm still
and that's the thing too it's hard
because like I do I love
um everyone who's in my space so much
um
but I have to keep like it's a separate
like that's me being in tune with men
and understanding men but in a romantic
relationship I'm still my own person and
I make mistakes and I you know and I
want to be loved I don't want to be
looked at as like you're the coach of
the relationship and you're gonna fix me
and so I need a man who has done his own
work and that's harder than finding a
man who's wealthy or anything because it
takes a lot of guts and a lot of
accountability to say like I've dove
into masculine feminine energy and also
to have him not be feminine right like
I'm in this weird weird gap of you know
I'm not saying it's impossible I think
it's actually better because you weed
out people so much easier right but I
don't think you'll have any problems I
definitely don't but I am but I
appreciate the honesty because I think a
lot of people have insecurities or
slight worries of how do you know how do
we find that perfect person for us and
when you're in a business where you're
doing the things you are doing yeah men
are insecure so you know you're talking
to men helping men and you know is is
that gonna you know make them feel but
like you say the right kind of guy will
appreciate that and say he has a woman
who understands men how can this not
benefit me in a relationship of course
it can you know because you speak the
language essentially you're fluent in
man fluent in man yeah and there's a
there's a
a question I'd like to ask before we
finish I'm going to ask you it now which
is how would you like to be remembered I
would like to be remembered for truly
helping people for having an impact on
people
this has become my life
like this like I don't have children I
don't have a partner and sometimes like
like life for me has been very lonely
um I'm not close with my family I jump
from country to Country I don't have
like these pillars of connection and so
you know selfishly I've kind of found it
through this work that I've done and
I've just it's so important to me
to have an impact on the World to not
make people feel so alone and to help
them feel understood and seen and
I I want to help everybody you know like
it's not enough for me to have just a
few people like I want everybody to feel
like they have something to look forward
to so I'd like to be remembered for like
really just trying to do my best I'm
just doing my best
that was a lovely answer and I really
rate your honesty in the vulnerability
that you shared there and I think uh as
someone who's just sort of getting to
know you and watching your journey I
just think being also focusing on you
and looking after you would be a great
part of that as well because you can
give too much to people can't you and
you deserve a lot do you know what I
mean you're a good person yeah but the
focusing on me you know like
the best like the most fulfillment I
have found has been from like helping
people out and I I focus on me by
bettering myself so they can be better
at this and then I think in the
background is like I would really like a
family I I want a strong family and
that's why I'm like not willing to
settle like I want one specific person I
don't want to get divorced I don't want
to have a broken family I want to have a
family unit something I didn't have and
I want to be included in their family
like because the ultimate thing at the
end of the day that we all need is love
like deep connected love like that's
what nobody regrets said at the end of
their lives but we regret so many other
things I think you're absolutely right
and we're definitely on the same page in
that respect and I'll remember this
quote about uh you you meet people in
life who are either radiators or drains
you know and you are a radiator so you
are all things you're definitely helping
people so well done I'm going to put all
the links uh below because I know a lot
of men out there will want to reach out
and and look at more of your work
because you have so many words of wisdom
that can help people and hopefully we'll
get you on again sometime yeah thank you
so much for being here that was at least
on the true Geordie podcast thanks for
watching and we'll see us later
[Music]
foreign